Welcome to the Empty Netters podcast. Can you believe what this has become? There was a full 48 hours where I felt like I was like literally Superman. Jumbo loves playing Fortnite, so he gets on the sticks. Did TR show you the sauna cycle or was that all year? No, no, I invented that. Almost a year now that I haven't taken a body check. That's kind of nice.
So we are back. We are horned up and we are going deep. Finish tonight with some chicken fingers and a few guineasasers and ran into you guys. That's where this pod came to life. Ice is ready and we are back with another episode of the Empty Netters podcast brought to you by BetMGM Vacation Dano continues here in Sweden. We got Evbot the doctor behind the sticks. Hi. And C.P. Broken Hands is back in studio.
A little sleaker this time. As always. It also smelled horribly. I don't know why I did that. I don't know. Cats. Don't love hearing that. What I do love is that we've got a great.
episode for you today. We've got some fun little unbreakable streak talk going on in the NHL. We've got great not ice nonsense. And it's Thursday so you know that fraud watch and top hits is back. I've got a great one. I feel very, very good about it. And I really feel good about these unbreakable streaks that CP has for us. Well, I, gentlemen, as I'm one to do when I'm bored, is I'm just cruising hockey boys. Bullshit. Bullshit. And there's this, and dude, we're going to get into something that I've been long screaming.
So I'm excited for your guys take. But there, I saw someone on Reddit kind of going off on a similar track that I've been going off on. And then it sent me down a rabbit hole of research. Stap Boy CP back in full swing. I love that. Before you get into stats, speaking of rabbit holes, can I just quickly say, Evan, are, Are you aware of the celebrities die in three's theory? Yeah, I've heard of that actually, yeah.
Has this ever hit harder and faster, Chris, than Hayden, Dolly, and Tim Curry? Did they all just die? Tim Curry passed, though. We just got the news this morning that he passed. Yeah, we lost Hayden last week, and then Dolly yesterday and Tim Graham. I did not hear about Tim Curry. That sucks. Absolutely.
devastating, but you better believe it means that we've got to watch Clue. You've got to watch scary movie, too. We've got to watch Fern Gully. Oh, we, yeah. Dude. We were bumping, we were bumping Dolly Parton in the house last night. I can't believe I was having such a good morning. And then now you've done this time.
I know, I'm sorry to do it to you. I mean, Tim had been in poor health for a while, so it's not like surprising, surprising, but it is a bummer, right? Dude, also. And Dolly, Dolly was 80, I think. And I'll tell you what, when you're a, When you are a legendary rock star like Dolly and you make it to 80, that's a, that's huge. That's a great win.
Treasure Island. Dude, it's, I got to say, not to ever make light of the dead. We would. Oh, boy. I don't do that. Where are you going? But I think if you are a celebrity. Evan, I'm bracing for you.
Yeah. I think if you are a celebrity in poor health and then two celebrities die like two days in a row, you are like, I'm, I'm, I am cooked. There's just no way it's not me. You must think that. You've got to be terrified. And that's not, that's not speaking.
Yeah, no. That's not speaking. I'm just saying, you got to be like, oh no. Like even when two, if you're a celebrity and two celebrities die and you're in good health,
you're still like, yikes. Everybody keep on your fucking toes. And then how about this CP? If you're a celebrity right now who is much, much older or in poor health, you're like,
yes. Yeah, you're right. Dude, it swings both ways. If you're in, there's multiple celebrities in poor health right now, I'm sure. So when you, when Dolly dies, all of them go, oh, fuck. But one of them pays the ultimate price and the other 10 live forever. Yeah, which makes Tim a here.
Yeah, thank you. And I, and I really do thank him for his service. What an incredible career. Yeah. Yeah, incredible career. So check out some Tim Curry movies. Please get into your rabbit hole. I'm sorry for that.
I'm sorry for that lane change. That's okay, dude. Now I got a fucking. Hold on. Pull us back up, dude. I, I, I, I know that hard bumping. I did a nose dive. Yep.
Get some Celsius going and pull us up from this nose dive. Oh, look at him. He's being energized. Woo! Have you tried the cherry coal of flavor yet? Fuck, I forgot about that one. That might be out of, they might have, they might be out of that one. It might have gone immediately.
Ev, that's so true. I'm sure the office went through that, like crack cocaine. Shout out Laz, again, two episodes in a row because he loves Stap Boy CP. I went down a rabbit hole of in my, and I found like a trillion NHL records, but I went down a rabbit hole of some that I wanted to discuss with you guys as the most unbreakable. Got it. And we're going to rank them. Like this one will literally never be, I don't know how many I have, but we're going to go and just put them in order. Okay.
Okay. And then as I was looking up, just to start us off, as I was looking up most unbreakable records in all of sports, which there are some doozies. Cal Ripkin's Iron Man Street comes up for baseball all the time. And I was like, oh, the NHL Iron Man could be broken, I think, because Phil Kessel just broke it, obviously. And I just want to see what number that is. And our boy Keith Yandel had set it at 989 games. And then Phil Kessel broke that almost immediately and set it at 1,064 games.
Wow. And I promise you I've not looked at this. I'm pretty sure, isn't Bernsey going to break that? this year. Dan, yes, Brent Burns is at 1,07 games. And then I was like, oh, but he's retiring. And then I was like, wait, he signed an extension in June. And I mean, now we fucked him, I guess, now that I'm saying this out loud, because he does have to not get hurt and play. But it is insane that he is just about to break this. I completely, that, that missed me somehow fully. And don't worry, Bernsey is bigger than, Bernsey is bigger than the two of us. Yes. We could
We could never jinx this. That's impossible. Yeah. I mean, if Phil can survive headbutting marshy, then Brent Burns can survive whatever ailments are going to give it to him. But actually, Dan, let's look up. I mean, I guess he's been logging just 82s, right? That's how this, that's how this streak works. That's, that is how the Iron Man works. Yeah. So he just has to go hard body karate and make it. But I think he will, which he does, dude. He's a far. That's extremely, that's extremely cool. And good for bread. He is built on non-GMO grass fed that he hunts. Local, local, local raw honey and milk.
Dude, he's, um, he's, um, he's in his beard. Yeah, it's in his beard. He keeps a little, what do you think keeps his hair up slick? Uh, he, um, he's like, here's our red rising crossover. He's like several. He's literally just out like killing elk with his teeth in his bare hands and in his farm and then comes in. He's like, dinner's ready. Yeah. I'm sure he walks into practice someday with blood all over his clothes and people are like, what were you doing? And he's like, just skinned a deer. Yeah. We're good. Ready for him. I'm a skate. I built my kitchen. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So here's, here's, I'm going to take you through the records. Okay. And then we'll rank him at the end. Dave Williams has the NHL record for PIMS penalty minutes, 3,966 in his career. And the
Next closest guy is at like 1,000 something. So it's like, it's a bloodbath. But in an 84 game season, because we're going to 84 now, don't forget with a lot of these, in an 84 game season, if someone joins the league next year and they had a 20 year career, if they took a minor penalty every game of the season for 20 years, they would be at 3,360. They'd still be 600 pym short of Dave Williams. Yeah. That will never even be.
But, dude, but like there are majors, though, you know, like, it's fighting guys that are like, oh. Well, that, but that's what I'm saying, dude, fighting is leaving the game. We're already fighting way less. Fighters are a dying breed that will never, ever, ever be sniffed. Can you imagine, too, if you took how many years into a career do you think you'd have to take a minor penalty every game before a coach was like, hey, douche? You, so let me tell you what, I was just thinking about that.
You would have to score every game as well. before through 20 games a coach would be like this, you're going to the mindsies pal. You are an absolute liability. You're a beer leagher. You're a beer leaguer. You're a beer leaguer. If you're genuinely coming out there in the national,
taking a penalty every single game, you would get through five games before a coach was like, what is the positive of having you out on the ice? Also, like, look at, if you look at a picture of Dave Williams, like he looks like he smokes two packs a day. He was probably like 25. in some of these pictures. But it's also like shifting demographics
where it's like younger, more affluent people are playing the sport now. Whereas like in the 70s, it was like rough and tumble dudes who would like work on an oil rig. You know, it was just a different type of guy and the league was way different. So it was so much more fighting,
but it's way different. They were coming up out of the coal. Yeah, yeah. And just part of it all. Dan, I don't imagine Dave took a lot of slashing. You know, like it wasn't like a lot of hacks. I bet a lot of cross-checks. I bet there was a couple spears in there, too.
Dude, I want to ask AI after this to break down Dave Williams' penalties by, by penalty and see what that cooks up. I bet it's gnarly, man. I bet Dave Williams was holding nothing back on those hacks too. Okay, so that's looking like Paul Bunyan out there. Good point, dude. Jesus Christ. Horrible.
A wooden coho going across the forearm from Dave Williams will send you back. No padding. No slash cards back then. So that's, for the people listening at home, that's 20-year career, a minor penalty every game, 84-game season, you'd still be under. I actually wonder how good would you have to be offensively for someone to live with that? If Connor McDavid took a penalty every game. You 100% live with that. Would the Oilers be like, yes, damn?
Guys, as a Penguins fan, Malkin almost takes a penalty every time. Yeah, like Malkin does get a lot of games, which is funny. He's a passionate play. Yeah, you don't care at all, dude. I think the production, Dan, would be lower than you think. Who did Malkin try to murder last year? Oh, you like cross-checked him in the mouth. Oh, yeah.
I forget the player. I forgot about that. I'm going to look it up. Malkins wires crossed heavy last season and he tried to murder somebody. Dan, you know when Dolan gets going on R-Bob and he's like, I'm too much of a vet to have to deal with this shit? That's what happens to Mollah. It was Rasmus Dahlene. It was.
It was Dahlene. He tried to murder. Malkin just is too much of a vet now to deal with shit. So he's like, I'll cross-check you in the face. What was funny is when that happened, a lot of people were like, Dahlene's an undercover rat. He probably had that comment. Yeah.
I was like, whoa. I love it. I love it. Okay. The next one, the next record I'm bringing up is a gentleman named Bill Mickelson. He has the NHL record for worst plus minus. In the 74-75 season, Bill finished a dash 82. Oh, my God.
And, Dan, he only appeared in 59 games that year. Oh, my God. Bill. No, Bill. No. When I saw a dash a game, I was like, oh, so, so hold on, hold on. So Billy, Billy Mix, is this is single season, single season, worst, plus minus.
For the capitals, right? For the caps, yeah. Yeah, they were pretty bad. He only had a 174 game career and he finished Dash 174. So he was, he was point per game on dash. This guy was committed. Dude, a dash 82, I started laughing so hard. And then when I saw only appeared in 59 games, I shit my pants, dude.
That is, I wanted to say dash 82 could be, I'm honestly slightly surprised that is still the worst. Really, Dan? I, dude, think about a couple of these teams we've seen in the last several years. And I think I'm legally allowed to say this because of how much we've pumped their tires coming forward here, because they are on a great trajectory. But even the most diehard Blackhawks fans will say, the Blackhawks team that was put out on the ice a couple of seasons ago was pretty tough.
And I think about the guys on those teams that are asked to do so much. And it's like, how could you possibly have a positive plus minus? Yeah, right. But that's just so many, dude. Dash 80s. Chris, that's one per me. Yeah, like it's so many.
The quick check. And it's like when you think, about how many games you need to be playing to have that bad of a plus minus. You got to think you're winning some games. But then you talk to a guy named Billy Mix and he's like, doesn't matter, dude. I'm on the ice. Dude, it's going in our net. You want to put me out there? It is going in our net. Can you imagine how good you must feel if you're in a bit of a slump and you step out on the ice and you see Billy Mix lining up against the face off dot from you? You're like,
boys, get it. I'm getting one. Don't have to dump it in. Find me in front. Don't have to dump it in on this shift, dude. Find me in front. So statmuse.com only gives you the first 25, worst plus minuses ever,
and then it locks it. So I can only see that. And the most recent one that's even in this mix is the 83 season. And it gets down to minus 54 is the 25th worst. So like we haven't even been close to dash 82. So I, dude, I just think if someone, was getting this bad dashed in today's league
you'd be gone. You're done so, dude. Because, like, this is also what Ev was talking about. It's like, if you, like, when Billy Mix was playing, dude, they were pulling guys off the sailbobs. Like, this. Billy couldn't skate, dude. Yeah, dude. Like, your Billy Mix was probably your local barber. And, like,
the capitals were like, dude, we're running low on bodies. We need you to pop out on out there on right D. And he was like, I mean, we're going to get scored on. Like, so, yeah, like, I don't, I think, like, we've got the Minesies now, if you're getting lit up like a Christmas tree this bad, you're getting sent down, dude. You're going to go to Providence. I'm sorry. You've got to plug some holes down there, dude,
and then maybe, then maybe you come back up. You might be going to the coast. Okay, so that one's up there, dude. That one's an early contender for like, that's a big time. Billy Mick. In dash 82, 59 games, legendary work. Okay, the next one that I have, Bobby Orr points by a defenseman in a single season. He had 139 points in the 70-71 season. And the interesting thing about this record is Paul Coffey had 138 points in the 8586, which is the closest has ever been. But it still feels pretty tough to get. Even though we were one point away once, I'm still like, God, I don't know if we're going to get there ever again. We have an annual moment where we just all have to raise a glass to Paul Coffey for the most overlooked player.
Yeah. History of sports, gentlemen, not hockey, the history of sports. I'll drink to that. Paul Coffey, if truly, if not for one Robert Orr, ball coffee would be considered one of the greatest, if not the greatest defensemen. And Raymond Bork, it's like two brewing defensemen, like completely caught Paul Coffee. Yeah. Bobby Orr and Ray Bork were put on this earth to ruin Paul Coffey's career. Fuck you.
It's insane. It's so funny. So you think that one's gettable, Dan. I feel like we're seeing 100 points and it's like a miracle. Like a defenseman gets 100 points and we're like, oh my God. You know what? I'm getting a little too horny here by saying definitely because what, sorry, what was that? 139, dude.
139 is that is an insane year for a forward right now. So I'm being a little horny saying it's definitely getable because we saw Carlson hit the Hyundai spot four or five years ago and that was preposterous. So listen, it's getable, but it's still very unlikely. Like, dude, that would have... Like, who is the last four to get up that high? Was that Connor? Dan, I'm going to tell you, since 1990 on...
139 has been done how many times, twice? One, two, three. So from 1990 on... on, Bobby Orr would have won the Art Ross every year but three. Oh, my God. Like, it's the most points in the league every year by three. Even last year, Dan Connor had 138. He would have lost by one point to Bobby Orr.
So I'm like, I don't know if we're ever going to see that, even though we got close once. It's like, that's going to be tough to sniff again, fellas. Matthew Schaefer, come on, baby. Shafor, dude, he's our only hope. Okay, let me stay with Bobby Orr. I actually, I think, like, if I'm betting on a horse right now to get that crazy. It's probably I think it's lame
Oh with the apples Actually I love that take down I think lane dude is like He's just dude He'd have like He's only gonna have a 20 goal season probably He's gonna have to have a 120 He's gonna have to have a 120 assists
You'd have to like literally set like this single season One of these single season assists records He can do it The kid almost had an assist per game last year Damn dude dude He's the anti Bill Mickelson. Fucking nails.
Bobby Orr finished the 7071 season plus 124. And the closest we've seen anyone get after the year 2000, because some of them are like kind of high, but just so old. Yeah. The closest we've ever seen anyone get after 2000 is Johnny Hockey was a plus 64 in the in the 2020-21 season. and that's in the top 50, but plus 124. That's like half, he was only halfway there.
I don't think we'll ever see that either. Like that is banana land to be plus 124. So wait, did you just say that that was the same season as the 139 points? Yeah, 139 points plus 124. Yeah, it's like, if you're going to sniff that, you've got to be an over 100 point guy. and you've also got to be on the biggest wagoon team in the league where you're like you have to have the best defense
and tendi as well otherwise you're not getting anywhere near that so like that I think it's way way more likely that someone could I think we're more likely to see a Billy mix than that honestly you actually you actually might be right because it's like a
the team's horrible and you're just the minutes eater you know you're like oh man I got to just play all games on D and we suck. Like you're the number one D man on the team that is absolutely fucking blown it the fuck up. It's like when, I'm not going to take a shot at any team in the league right now.
But when a team soon here goes like this, we're blowing it up. And there's one horse on D that they don't get rid of. And they go like this, you're playing 30 minutes. Yeah. And he goes like this. Did you just sign me to a Billy Mix contract?
And they say, Dude, I actually want to look, Dan, because, no, he's actually done, well, he's had a couple tough ones. Because this, this sounds a lot like Mario, who has just been grinding on some of those sharks teams. Like, literally, he was playing 23 minutes a night on horrible sharks teams, just being like, I'll do it, you know, like falling on grenades. And he got up there.
That one year, he had minus 38. But even that, like, Billy was dashed 82. Insane. What a fucking piece. Okay. to the next one. Here comes CP Controversal Take Part 1. Marty Brodor NHL record career
691 wins. And this is often listed boys as like one of the unbreakable NHL records. For context, Flower just retired with 575. So well over a hundred short. So it's like, oh my God, Marty, you're insane. Bob has 456.
So like well over 200. hundred short. And Bob feels like this long-aged legend, okay? The thing about this one, sorry. No, you can interject here. I have some data points, but go ahead. The thing about this one is, we forget it's rare. Like, Marty was starting when he was like 22. And playing like 70 games a year. Yeah, they would ride the one goalie a lot more than they do now. But my point was, even before that fact, guys don't really get the net until like 25. That is also a good point, Dan. So like that it's a, Marty was a perfect storm of an era where they rode him like fucking Seattle slew and made him play 70 plus games a season. They were, they were also on a
wagon team and he was starting at the same time he could drink a fucking beer legally. That combination, that trifecta ain't happening in that. And he's nasty. Like that helps too, right? Like he was very, very good. And he is a weapon. So here's the only thing I want to bring up to you guys. Marty played 22 years, which is fucking nutso, right? But I can't remember what we saw flower, 20 or 21. Like, it happens. Okay, Bob's getting up there, right? If a goalie started now and had a 20-year career, so two years less than Marty,
but if you had a 20-year career, which is a lot, they need to win 34.55 games per season, which is, like, obscene. That's so good for 20 years to break this record. However, Vassi, since he became a starter, Vassi's been a starter for 10 years, and he's averaged 35.2 wins, so he's over it. And again, he'd have to do that for 10 more years, but I'm kind of like, this feels less impossible than when you hear it out loud to me. Like when you hear flowers, 120 shy, you're like, no one could ever do this. But now I'm like, someone could do this. Vassi ain't doing it, but I am going to, I'm going to leave Vassi,
but I'm going to stay in the same nation. Evan, how old is Ascaroff? Let me look I think Ascroft's like 23 Because like And listen 24 Rush
Okay But still Russian machine Don't break He's already got the Starting job How many wins does he have already The sharks
The sharks might be a fucking Like what if they become a 20 year dynasty with Mac And Ascroft's just the goalie the whole time His career records 26 wins 27 loss Yes you've got 26 in the
cap already. And now he has to play for like 18 years. Can't get hurt. It'd be tight. But dude, he could be winning like 40 games a year, you know. Well, that's the thing. It's like you got to look at like, I think Knight, Knights, maybe the same age, 25 or so. Oh, good one. I think he's a little older. Look up how old Sp-I. I think so too, actually, maybe, because he's been, but like, Spencer Knight is 26 max, is what I would guess. He is 25. Okay. See, like Spencer Knight's an interesting one too. 68 regular season wins. You got to have the combination to have a team that is on the precipice of like a 20-year
domination. I mean, dude, like let's not forget about Sway. Like, Sway's only 27. He actually probably has a lot of wins already versus like Spencer Nights. Yeah, that's what I'm saying. He's probably got a lot of wins already. And Sway, dude, he's got that, you know, he's Alaska tough. He's playing until he's fucking 45.
He's also a sicker. Yeah, see Sway's basically there. Sway's halfway there. Okay, I actually now think Sway is the frontrunner dead. It's Sway or Asgraf are the only two that could hunt down Marty Brodor? And he's 27. So, fuck, he is 27. I think, God, I'm on fire with the numbers.
No, I'm not. I fucking got Spencer Knight way wrong. But I, listen, this one's not, we're not ranking it yet, but this one, I was just surprised to see when I did the math and I went divided by years, I thought it was going to be like, you have to average 42 wins here. And I was like, okay, this is dead. But when it said 34, I was like, that's not dead dead. It would take a fucking insane run.
But very interesting. Okay. Next one I'm going to is, and there's a couple of Waynos in here that I'm building to a larger point. But next one I'm going to is Wayno most assists in a single season, single season. He did it in the 85, 86 season. He had 163 assists. And that was when it was an 80 game schedule. So.
Never. Absolutely. Because Connor and Cooch had 100 and it felt like a literal miracle. Yeah, and then you need 60 plus more of those. You have to do like a full season. Literally never. Yeah. So never in a million years.
That one feels very hard. Okay, the next record, the New York Islanders consecutive playoff series wins. Consecutive playoff series wins. From 80 to 84, the New York Islanders won 19 straight playoff series. Oh my gosh. What? That's probably number one.
That's probably wild. That is the craziest stat I have ever heard in my life. because that's also not like in the fucking 20s when there were three teams, you know? That was like the other day. That's like five cups in a row. They won four cups in and then lost in the cup final of the fifth year. In the cup final. Yeah, so they won four, four, four, three.
And then lost to Gretzky in the Oilers. And then Gretzky won a million in a row. God, man. Can you imagine trying to beat that team as the Oilers? Oh my God. Dude, yeah, right. Because Gretzky's already great at that time, but the islanders were just dominating. And they had bossy who's like, who's my goat?
That must have been the coolest cup of all that. Oh, wow, what a good point, dude. That's two tigers. You're taking down a literal god. Like that is insane. I mean, Ev, you have watched some epic penguins runs and Dan, we got one cup out of it, but like we had some great Bruins runs. Imagine winning 19 straight playoff series.
Dan, put it to Brady. Like, even like, I'm like, I'm a Tom Brady fan. In my mind, I've watched the greatest dynasty ever. We lost Super Bowls. You know, like the Islanders just literally one playout series over and over and over and Over at over. Crazy record. And it wasn't that long ago.
Like, it's not like they were doing this in the 50s. You know, like this is mental. Totally agree, dude. Like, that is, that one is moronic. Okay. Like, that happened. Like, our dad is alive. Oh, yeah, watch it.
And he was like, damn, the Islanders are good. Like, he was, like, thinking about making you at that moment. Whoa, true, dude. Like, I actually kind of ended the Islander's dynasty now that I think about it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's tough, dude. Bossy. Dude, it's actually fucked because.
Mike Bossy is such a hero of mine, and he probably deeply hates me now. Now that I'm, you arrived and he went like this. My back hurts too bad. This is boring now. This actually would be so bad, Dan. What year did his back go out and then he retired? Yeah. I think it was literally a year.
1987. He scored 38 goals and quit hockey right when I was born. Dude, you literally ended Mike Bossy's career and the Islanders dynasty. That is such a dagger. That's tough. dude. That's tough to hear. God damn it. Okay. Wayno, career assists, 1,963. So Connor McDavid right now is 29 years old. To break this record, McDavid would have to play 12 more years, which I believe he could. He's 29. But he would have to have 96 assists a season for the next 12 years.
Yeah, dude. That feels very tough. That feels very tough. I'm telling you, Chris, I'm telling you right now, where you wanted to do, this is already too long of a conversation and you wanted us to rank these. We're not ranking. No, no, we can't. I'm telling you.
No, we are not because you, last episode proved, if we try to rank anything, it takes 10x longer than anyone wants it to. So we are not doing it. This will be easy, Dan. This will be easy. Most goals,
I'm telling you right now, I refuse. I will not participate. I will give you the ranking in speed. We can go through and we can rank them on a scale of one to 10 how hard it is if you want, but we are not
putting these in order. Okay, I could do that. Timu, most goals by a rookie, 76 by a rookie. Can be broken. Ovi is the closest in recent memory and he only had 52 and he's a freak. So I'm like 76 goals is a rookie. We haven't seen 70 goals in like since Brett Hall, I think. Like 70 goal mark is impossible. We are going to 84 games, but like holy shit. Again, dude, we're talking with some of these things that you've listed are the most impossible things I've ever heard in my life. Fair. That one is like, it could happen. I don't know.
把这些按顺序排列。好吧，我可以做到。蒂姆，新秀单季最多进球，新秀赛季打进76球。这个纪录是可以被打破的。奥维是近年最接近的人，但他只有52球，而且他是个怪物。所以我觉得新秀赛季76球……自从布雷特·赫尔之后，我们大概就没见过单季70球了，我觉得。70球的门槛简直是不可能的任务。我们要打84场比赛，但这他妈太离谱了。再说一次，老兄，我们讨论的你列出的有些事情，是我这辈子听过最不可能发生的事。也有道理。那一项嘛……可能还是会发生吧。我不知道。
Okay. Next one, the Montreal Canadiens, 10 straight finals appearances. Yeah, that's not happening again. Literally never. No. Just the way teams are built now. Literally never. And this one, Dan, compared to the Islanders one, they did this when there was six teams.
好吧。下一个，蒙特利尔加拿大人队，连续10次闯入总决赛。是的，这绝不可能再发生了。字面意义上的绝不可能。不会。仅仅是因为现在球队的建队方式。绝对不可能。还有这个，丹，跟纽约人队那个比起来，他们做到这一点的时候联盟才只有六支球队。
Yeah. Right? So like this is why. The Islanders one is even more insane because there was actually fucking a league. No, never in a million years. Okay. This might be my favorite. Actually, I'm going to save that.
对吧？所以原因就在这。纽约人队的那个更疯狂，因为当时真的他妈的好歹算是个成熟的联盟。不，绝无可能，绝对没有。好吧。这可能是我最喜欢的一个。其实，我要把这个留到后面。
that one. How many more do you have? This is out of great. More more. Rocket Richard most cups as a player. Eleven. You could be broken. You think so? 11 cups? 100%. I mean, dude, like, again, these are all, like, I want to slap you right now. These are all seven or a lot in the ricketer scale. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
那个。你们还有多少个？这真是太棒了。更多，更多。莫里斯·理查德作为球员赢得最多总冠军。十一个。这纪录能被打破吗？你觉得呢？11个冠军？百分之百。我是说，老兄，这些……再次强调，我真想现在就给你一巴掌。这些在里查德的评分体系里都是7分或者极高。哦，对啊。哦，对啊。
That's what I wanted to wreck them. But like you're talking could it ever happen? Like, yeah. Like, I don't know. Like a guy, you know, let's say a guy gets, let's say the Panthers win another. And then like a young guy, like Lundell gets traded and he gets a to the next dynasty and they went four. You know, it's like, could happen. Okay, I like that take.
这就是我想给它们的分数。但如果你在讨论它有没有可能发生？就像，是的。比如，我不知道。假设有一个家伙，比如说美洲豹队又赢了一次。然后一个年轻球员，像伦德尔被交易了，他加入了下一个王朝球队并且连赢了四个。你知道的，这就像是，有可能发生。好吧，我喜欢这个观点。
OV goals, 929 and counting. And this is controversial CP take number two. I've been saying this a long time. And you clearly, not clearly, obviously you need health. Like OV's durability has been everything. Yeah. And Matthews is already proving like he's missing time in here and there. But I just, in the same way I thought it was interesting for Marty.
奥维的进球数，929个还在增加。这是CP的第二个具有争议性的观点。我很久以前就这么说了。而你显然……也不是显然，很明显你需要保持健康。就像奥维的耐用性至关重要。是的。而且马修斯已经证明了，他时不时就会缺阵。但我只是觉得，就像我之前觉得玛蒂的那样。
Matthews is 28. If he played 12 more years, he would need 41 goals a year. which doesn't sound like that many for an elite goal score. Like, he scores 50, 60 goals a season. No, dude. You just said this guy who's already had some injury problems needs to play until he's 43. No, no, 40.
马修斯28岁。如果他再打12年，他每年需要进41个球。听起来对一个顶级射手来说似乎不算太多。比如，他一个赛季能进50、60个球。不，老兄。你刚才说这个已经有过伤病隐患的家伙需要一直打到43岁。不，不，40岁。
I gave him until 40. 12 more years at 28. I'm like, okay. And he needs to score 45 goals a year. 40. 41. But like, if he scores, if he has another 65 year, now he can afford a 15 year. You know, like, there's, you can get that average up so, like, he just has to be good
我算到他40岁。从28岁起再打12年。我想，好吧。他每年需要进45个球。40。41。但如果他进球，如果他再来一个65球的赛季，那他现在就能承担一个15球的低谷了。你知道的，这样你就能把平均数拉高，所以他只需要在他……
in his prime. Right. That's all I mean. It's just more possible than people think. I would put it lower on the list. Everyone's going OV's like, this is unbreakable. And I'm like, we could get it. It's possible, but Matthews ain't your guy.
的巅峰期表现出色。对吧。这就是我的意思。这其实比人们想象的更有可能发生。我会把它在名单上排低一点。每个人都觉得奥维的纪录是这样的，这根本无法打破。而我觉得，我们是有可能达成的。这是有可能的，但马修斯可不是那个人选。
Okay, this one's hilarious. Glenn Hall, most consecutive games played as a goalie. So the goalie Iron Man, 502 straight games. Like, he played every game of the season. When did Glenn Hall die? No, dude, he died the other day. Remember? I'm joking.
好吧，这个太搞笑了。格伦·霍尔，作为守门员连续出场场次最多。也就是守门员界的铁人，连续502场比赛。也就是说，他打满了赛季的每一场比赛。格伦·霍尔是什么时候去世的？不，老兄，他前几天刚去世。记得吗？我开玩笑呢。
Yeah, actually glide. He died January 7th of this year. Dude, 53 or 55 to 63, he just played every game of the season. Like literally their backup did not play. He died at 94. He's the Iron Man of Life. He's a legend, dude. That is unbelievable. Okay. And then the Peace Day Resistence, which is why I brought this whole thing up, and I'm going to read you this quick blur, because I actually would love your guy's takes on this because I thought it was amazing. Yeah, go ahead. This is what I found, because usually the most unbreakable record in sports unanimously is Wayne's points.
对，其实克莱德。他是今年1月7日去世的。老兄，从53或55年到63年，他打满了赛季的每一场比赛。字面意义上他们的替补都没上过场。他活到94岁。他是生活中的铁人。他是个传奇，老兄。这太不可思议了。好吧。然后是重头戏，这也是我把整件事提出来的原因，我要给你们读一读这段简短的摘要，因为我其实很想听听你们对这个的看法，我觉得这太棒了。好的，说吧。这就是我找到的，因为通常在体育界大家一致认为最不可打破的纪录是韦恩的积分。
Like, everybody says that because the closest is like thousands of points away, you know, or a thousand points away or something. So listen to this breakdown, and what do you think, Dan? This is the Reddit person. Shout out, Notorious LLL.L. Gretzky has 2,857 points in 1,487 games, plus 382 in 208 playoff games, 21 seasons played till he's 38. McDavid is at 794 games, 1,220 points. I'm going to ignore our playoffs because I don't care right now. He needs 209 points to get to half of Gretzky's total,
就像，每个人都这么说，因为最接近的也差了几千个分，你知道的，或者差了一千分左右。所以听听这个数据拆解，你怎么看，丹？这是Reddit上的网友。向Notorious LLL致敬。格里兹基在1487场比赛中得到2857分，加上208场季后赛中的382分，打了21个赛季直到38岁。麦克戴维目前打了794场比赛，得到1220分。我先忽略我们的季后赛，因为我现在不在乎这个。他还需要209分才能达到格里兹基总数的一半。
which will take him 1.5 seasons at last year's 130 point pace. Does that sound fair? Yeah. In one and a half seasons, he'll have 209 points, which will put him exactly half of Gretzky. Which would mean he'd be at 15, 20 points heading into his 14th season at age 31. He would now need 1,3,3. 338 points to do it. If McDavid's true prime lasts for six more years, and he's able to rack up
按照去年的130分节奏，这将花掉他1.5个赛季。这听起来公平吗？是的。在一个半赛季里，他将得到209分，这正好是格里兹基的一半。这意味着他在进入31岁的第14个赛季时将得到1520分。他现在还需要133338分才能达成。如果麦克戴维的真正巅峰期还能持续六年，并且他能够积攒……
150 points, his best season was 153, which is obviously a lot, that's 900. So he'd be 438 left at age 37. Assuming better sports medicine actually makes an impact, he could play till 42. So five seasons left at 37, 24 seasons total. Chelyos and Howe played 26 seasons, so that's well within the realm of possibilities. It all depends on how healthy and McDavid can stay and how he can change his game as he slows down. You'd think at some point at his salary dwindles he'll be able to facilitate some really good scores and keep up racking assists. At this point, he would need 88 points a season for his final five seasons, which is 60% of his peak. OVee in his 24th season, 21st season, is scoring at 60% of his peak, so it feels possible. So it is very possible because you don't
150分，他最好的赛季是153分，这显然很高，那就是900分。所以在37岁时他还差438分。假设更好的运动医学真的能发挥作用，他可以打到42岁。所以在37岁时还剩5个赛季，总共24个赛季。切利奥斯和豪打了26个赛季，所以这完全在可能性范围内。这一切都取决于麦克戴维能保持多健康，以及当他速度变慢时如何改变他的打法。你会觉得，在某个时候，随着他的薪水缩水，他将能够促成一些非常好的得分并继续积累助攻。此时，他在最后五个赛季里平均每季需要88分，这相当于他巅峰期的60%。奥维在他第24个赛季，第21个赛季，正以巅峰期60%的速度得分，所以这感觉是有可能的。因此这非常有可能，因为你不需要……
need to have McDavid produce the numbers he's already producing, just need to say consistent and ready to play until he's 42. And he's an assist king just like Gretzky. So if those numbers hit McDavid would hit Gretzky's numbers, and he seems like such a student of the game that I feel like if he was within reach of Gretzky's all-time record, he would come back and play one more year at, you know, get 40 points and do it.
让麦克戴维打出他已经打出的疯狂数据，只需要保持稳定并准备好一直打到42岁。而且他就像格里兹基一样是个助攻王。所以如果这些数据兑现，麦克戴维将追平格里兹基的数据，而且他看起来对比赛如此钻研，我觉得如果他真的触手可及格里兹基的历史纪录，他会选择回归再打一年，你知道的，拿到40分来达成这个目标。
Like, I don't think McDavid would retire 35 points shy of Gretzky's all-time record. This record, I thought, was literally not even in the scope of anything, but with this math, it's actually not that crazy. What are your thoughts? I agree. Like, that is nuts, dude.
就像，我不认为麦克戴维会在距离格里兹基历史纪录仅差35分的时候退役。我原本以为这个纪录简直连讨论的范围都进不了，但有了这个数学推导，其实并没有那么疯狂。你们怎么看？我同意。这太疯狂了，老兄。
I don't mean for this to be boring conversation, but agree. Like I think it is Connor literally wrote an article this year about how he's a robot. And I don't know that we're going to see a change in Connors. I must get 120 plus points of season attitude in a long time. So I think that this is going to continue. And I think he is a genuine alien on the ice. And I can see him sniffing. Because, dude, asking for 150 a season for the next,
我不是故意要把天聊死，但我同意。就像我认为康纳……今年甚至写了一篇文章，讲述他自己是如何像个机器人的。而且我不知道我们什么时候才会看到康纳的心态发生变化。我必须每赛季拿到120分以上的态度短时间内不会改变。所以我认为这种情况会继续下去。而且我认为他在冰球场上简直是个真正的小外星人。我甚至能看到他去接近那个纪录。因为，老兄，要求接下来的……
like six years is a big ask, obviously. But asking for 88 as he ages, even though that's a point for game, it just doesn't feel that crazy for him because of the assists. You know, I'm like, whatever, dude. Like, you will obviously have 88 fucking points.
大概六年里每年都拿到150分，这显然是个很高的要求；但要求他在老去时拿到88分，即便那是一场均一分，考虑到他的助攻，这对他也并不显得那么疯狂。你知道的，我觉得，管他呢，老兄。你显然能拿到他妈的88分。
And God, remember how crazy it was with Ovi when he got close? If Connor got close to this record as he was at age 41 and shit, it would be awesome. Like the fucking buzz would be insane. It would be so cool to watch. All right.
天哪，还记得当奥维接近纪录时有多疯狂吗？如果康纳在41岁左右接近这个纪录的话，那该有多酷啊。那种轰动效应绝对会疯狂。看这个过程会太酷了。好了。
Let's go through and rate these before this conversation gets to an hour long, which is insanity. But let's go for it. Okay. The Bobby Orr points by a defenseman. Why are you not going in order? Dave Williams Pims. Okay. Literally 10. 10. Never be broken. Billy Mick dash 82. I will, I'll be willing to say like an eight. Do you go loud? Should we go decimals here? Let's go like an 8.5. 8.5. We can go half. I can't believe that. Because again, I could see what you brought up in like a horse defenseman on a brutal rebuilding team that's getting blown up. Bobby Orr 139 points in a single season. For a defenseman. Eight. Eight. Okay. I don't think anything's going to be below me. I can't believe that's the lowest one. Bobby Orr plus 124 in a single season. I think 10. Truly I do. I think you might be right. Actually, make that one.
在我们把天聊到一个小时这么疯狂之前，让我们把这些过一遍并打个分吧。不过我们还是开始吧。好吧。鲍比·奥尔的后卫得分纪录。你为什么不按顺序来？戴夫·威廉姆斯的罚球分钟数。好吧。简直是10分。10分。永远无法打破。比利·米克负82。我愿意给个8分。你要放大声音吗？我们这里要用小数吗？来个8.5分吧。8.5分。我们可以用半数。我真不敢相信那个。因为同样地，我能想象到你提到过的场景，一个惨淡重建期球队里的拼命后卫，整支球队都被打爆了。鲍比·奥尔单赛季139分。作为后卫。8分。8分。好吧。我觉得没什么会比我的低。我简直不敢相信那是最低的。鲍比·奥尔单赛季正负值正124。我觉得是10分。真的，我确实这么觉得。我觉得你可能是对的。其实，把那个改成……
9.5 and make the PIMS 9.5 also, Evan. Okay. No, dude. Pems, we're allowed to go to 10 here. I know, but there are things way bigger than that one. But, no, but those will also be tens. Like, if something is impossible and another thing's even more impossible, they're both equally impossible because they're impossible. Both of those are tens.
9.5分，把罚球分钟数也改成9.5分吧，埃文。好吧。不，老兄。罚球分钟数，我们这里允许打到10分。我知道，但有些事情比那个重大得多。但是，不，但那些也都是10分。如果某件事是不可能的，而另一件事更加不可能，那它们同样都是不可能的，因为它们根本不可能发生。这两项都是10分。
Marty Broder, 691 wins. 9.5. I consider a 10th. Okay. We'll go in 9.5 because I was considering a 10%. 9. Wayno assists in a single season 163. Me too.
马丁·布德尔，691场胜利。9.5分。我认为是10分。好吧。我们给9.5分，因为我刚才在考虑给10%。9分。韦恩单赛季助攻163次。我也是。
Literally never. Islanders 19 consecutive playoff series wins. 11. The biggest 10 of all 10. Yeah. Wayno 1,963 career assists. 9.5, but probably 10?
字面意义上的绝不可能。纽约人队连续19场季后赛系列赛胜利。11分。所有10分里最大的10分。是的。韦恩生涯1963次助攻。9.5分，但可能是10分？
10, dude. Like McDavid. Just go 10. 10. Timu goals by a rookie 76. 8.5. Okay. Okay. Habs, 10 straight finals appearances. 15.
10分，老兄。就像麦克戴维一样。直接给10分。10分。蒂姆的新秀进球76个。8.5分。好吧。好吧。加拿大人队连续10次进入总决赛。15分。
Yeah. No, dude, this is the 15. Make Habs 11 with the Islanders. Glenn Hall, 502 straight games as a goalie. Literally, no goalie will even play 82 games ever again. Literally, no goalie will ever play a full season, ever again. That is actually correct. This one is 15.
是的。不，老兄，这个是15分。把加拿大人队和纽约人队一样改成11分吧。格伦·霍尔，作为门将连续出场502场。说实话，以后再也不会有任何门将单赛季打满82场比赛了。字面意义上，再也不会有门将打满一个完整的赛季了。这其实很对。这个是15分。
That's the craziest record I've ever seen. Henri Rechard, 11 cups as a player. 8.5. Yeah, 8.5, maybe 9. OV career goals. I mean, God, I'm being a little crazy. 11 is insane, yeah. The most ridiculous scenario of all time. I was trying to, I think, that's possible. That's probably a 9. Yeah, 9. Make that one a 9. Let's call it a 9. OV goal record. I think at 9. 8.5. Let's go down 8.5. 8.5. 8.5.
这是我见过最疯狂的纪录。亨利·理查德，作为球员赢得11个冠军。8.5分。对，8.5分，也许9分。奥维的生涯进球数。我是说，天哪，我有点太疯狂了。11分太疯狂了，是的。有史以来最荒谬的剧本。我刚才在想，我觉得，这是可能的。那大概是个9分。对，9分。把那个定为9分吧。就叫9分。奥维的进球纪录。我觉得算9分。8.5分。我们降到8.5分。8.5分。8.5分。
Yeah, and then Wayno career points, which I thought was a fucking 20. Now looking at it, I think we have to go 9.5. Yeah, All right. Let's go 9.7 for Connor. Oh, there you go. Oh, fuck yes, dude. Give him a little juice.
是的，然后是韦恩的生涯总积分，我之前觉得这他妈是个20分。现在看来，我觉得我们得给9.5分。对，好吧。给康纳打9.7分吧。哦，来了。哦，操，太棒了，老兄。给他加点油。
Incredible. All right. So those are the most unbreakable records in NHL history and it turns out some of them are kind of breakable. And Statman CP, like those, that was great digger out.
不可思议。好吧。这些就是NHL历史上最不可打破的纪录，结果证明其中有些其实还是有点可能被打破的。而且数据统计员CP，像那些，真是太精彩的挖掘了。
Those are all crazy. 500 and two straight games as a goalie is the funniest thing I've ever seen in my life. Those are all in the sense. How did he still have a face? Dude, I was like, what do you do it? Like, why did you,
这些全都很疯狂。作为门将连续出场500场比赛是我这辈子见过最搞笑的事。这些全都有意义。他怎么还能有脸？老兄，我当时想，你是怎么做到的？比如，你为什么……
what was the backup saying for five years? Was he like, can I play? I don't think he existed, Chris. I don't think he existed. I don't think he existed. Dude, it was Bill standing in the net. That's why he was a dash 82. He's like he wouldn't have pads on. That's that's unbelievable stuff. We're taking an ad break. We'll be right back. Uh-oh. Do you smell that? Do you smell that autumn crisp? Do you smell that pumpkin spice? I know. I know. I don't like it either. But listen, Thursday night football is back. And it just got a whole lot better with the legendary Thursdays at Bet, MGM.
替补队员这五年里都在说些什么？他会说：“我能上场吗？”我觉得他根本不存在，克里斯。我觉得他不存在。我觉得他根本不存在。老兄，那是比尔站在网前。难怪他是负82。他就像是不穿护具一样。这实在是太不可思议了。我们要进一段广告。马上回来。哦哦。你闻到了吗？你闻到那个秋天的香脆味了吗？你闻到那个南瓜香料味了吗？我知道。我知道。我也不喜欢它。但是听着，周四夜橄榄球赛回归了。有了美高梅博彩的传奇周四，这一切变得更加精彩。
Every single week, every single Thursday. We were doing summer Thursdays. Now we're doing fall Thursdays. Every single week, you get a pro football, no sweat token if your qualifying wager doesn't hit and you get bonus bucks back, which is unbelievable. If you want to play a player prop, bang. You want to bet defense has your back? All good.
每一个单一的星期，每一个星期四。我们曾经有夏日周四。现在我们有了秋日周四。每一个星期，你都能获得一个职业橄榄球无风险代币，如果你符合条件的下注没有命中，你会拿回返还的奖金筹码，这简直不可思议。如果你想玩球员道具投注，砰。你想押防守端支持你？没问题。
If your player gets injured in the first quarter, you receive your cash back. Also, take advantage of BetMGM's odds flash for the best pricing on the game. Legendary Thursdays. They are only at BetMGM this fall. And if you haven't signed up for BetMGM yet, do it right now. use that promo code netters. That's N-E-T-T-E-R-S when you sign up and you can claim your new player offer. God, we are so back.
如果你的球员在第一节受伤，你就能拿回现金。另外，还可以利用美高梅博彩的赔率闪现来获得比赛的最佳赔率。传奇周四。今年秋天只在美高梅博彩。如果你还没有注册美高梅博彩，现在就去。注册时使用促销代码netters。也就是N-E-T-T-E-R-S，然后你就可以领取你的新玩家优惠了。天哪，我们太回归了。
I know you were waiting for this legendary Thursdays. Come on. That M-G-M makes it legendary. All right, let's get into fraud watch and top hits. It is Thursday, after all. I said I was very excited about one of mine here today. And now that I think about it, I might be excited about both. Do either of you want to kick us off?
我知道你一直在等待这个传奇周四。来吧。美高梅博彩让这一切变得传奇。好了，让我们进入欺诈观察和热门点击环节。毕竟今天是周四。我说过我今天对其中的一个非常兴奋。现在想来，我对两个都很兴奋。你们两个谁想带个头？
Let's start with Fraud Watch, as we always do. Either of you want to start? Sure, I'll start. And I had a couple, and I'm going to go with this one, because one of them kind of surer to buddy of mine, and I don't want to do that right now. I'm in too good a mood. Oh, boy.
我们照常从“欺诈观察”开始。你们谁想开始？当然，我来。我有几个，我打算选这个，因为其中一个有点对不起我哥们，我现在不想这么做。我今天心情太好了。哦，天哪。
This one might get some pushback. And I couldn't figure out how to phrase it, but I'm going to phrase it this way. I think that not, if you're out to dinner with your significant other, not splitting I'm putting on fraud watch like you are at a restaurant and you have the chance to try two things
这个可能会引起一些反弹。而且我想不出该怎么措辞，但我打算这样措辞。我认为，如果你和你的另一半出去吃晚晚餐，不分着……我要把这个列入欺诈观察，就像你在一家餐厅，你有机会尝试两样东西……
and you're with your significant other I'm like get... Oh, I thought you meant the bill. No, I thought you meant the bill. You each get something like you should go what should we get? Let's get two things here and then we'll try. We each get to try both.
而且你是和你的另一半在一起，我就想……哦，我以为你指的是账单。不，我以为你指的是账单。你们俩各点一样，比如你们应该去想，我们该点什么？我们在这里点两样，然后我们分着尝。我们俩都能尝到两样。
And because if you end up getting, if you accidentally order the worst thing, your meal is saved by getting the better thing that he or she ordered. And if he or she ordered the worst thing, you are now saving the meal of someone you love because you're like, hey, you get to try some of this too. Nice, hey, nice attempt at a spin zone at the end there, you fucking loser.
因为如果你最终点到了，如果不小心点到了最难吃的东西，你的这顿饭就被他或她点的那个更好吃的菜给拯救了。而如果他或她点到了最难吃的东西，你现在就在拯救你所爱之人的饭局，因为你会说，嘿，你也可以尝尝我这个。得了吧，最后还强行挽尊，你个他妈的失败者。
You're, like, you try to make it seem like when you're getting half of your great meal taken. It's a good thing because I thought some people were going to go, this thing sucks because I want to defeat my significant other. And I'm like, that's kind of weird, dude. Nice try. I think it's a missed opportunity. If you're at a great restaurant with your chief another, do not try two things. listen you're going to get no pushback from me i'm i'm just pulling your leg with that comment there i i
你就像，你试图把别人吃掉你的一半美食这件事，说成是一件好事，因为我以为有些人会觉得，这事太烂了，因为我想击败我的另一半。而我觉得，这有点奇怪，老兄。好样的。我觉得这是一个错失的机会。如果你和一个好伴侣在一家很棒的餐厅，却不尝试两种不同的菜，听着，你从我这里得不到任何反弹，我只是拿那句话逗你玩呢，我……
personally i would revise your statement to not being open to it is on fraud okay because i get that's just my take you can your your your fraud watch uh there are definitely times where we're at somewhere that we go too often and i'm like i know exactly what i want i don't want anything else i don't want to have half of your inferior dish, given what my taste buds want right now. I would like all of mine. So there are times we're on like, I think I should have said new restaurant, Dan. I think like if you're at a new spot, I'm like, yeah, try, try two things. Now we're cooking. Because like, yeah, there are definitely times where I know exactly what I want and I don't need to do it. But at a new place especially, or like if you're on vacation, I'm all in on Splitsville. Splitsville.
我个人会把你的说法修正为“对这种做法不开放才属于欺诈”，好吗？因为我懂，这只是我的看法，你可以……你的欺诈观察，确实有时候我们在某个去得太频繁的地方吃饭，我会想：我非常清楚自己想吃什么，我不想吃别的，在我的味蕾现在正渴望某种东西的时候，我才不想吃你那盘逊色的一半菜呢。我想全部吃掉我自己的。所以有时候我们会觉得，我觉得我应该说是一家新餐厅，丹。我觉得如果你在一家新店，我会觉得，对，尝尝两样。这才有意思。因为，是的，确实有时候我很清楚自己想吃什么，不需要那么做。但特别是在一家新餐厅，或者如果你在度假，我绝对全力支持“分食城”。分食城。
I was going to say this too. This was the original phrasing of my fraud watch. Ordering the same thing as your significant other at a restaurant is on fraud watch. Oh, that is. Because I'm like, that's insane. What are you doing, dude? I agree. I hate that because sometimes I'll be like looking at the menu and I'm like, oh, I think I'm going to get the, you know, the chicken parm or whatever.
我也正要这么说。这其实是我最初的“欺诈观察”措辞：在餐厅里点和你的另一半一模一样的菜，这绝对应该上欺诈观察。哦，那确实是。因为我觉得，这太疯狂了。你到底在干什么，老兄？我同意。我很讨厌那样，因为有时我会看着菜单心想，哦，我打算点那个，你知道的，鸡肉帕尔马干酪或者别的什么。
And then I'm with somebody like, oh, I'm going to get the chicken farm. I'm like, God damn it. Now I can't get it. Yeah, dude. If you're going to get it. So agree. Sometimes there's a Mexican restaurant Sandra and I go to sometimes after golf. And I'm like, I always want, we both just want the fajitas.
然后跟我在一起的人说，哦，我要点那个鸡肉帕尔马干酪。我就想，操。现在我不能点了。是的，老兄。如果你要点的话。所以完全同意。有时候我和桑德拉在打完高尔夫后会去一家墨西哥餐厅。我心里想，我总是想要……我们俩其实都只想要法士达。
So I'm like, oh, I have the steak fajitas. And she's like, me too. And I'm like, we are fucking loses. Like, this is insane. We can't do this. It's a tough look. It does make you look like a boring ass. Like, hey, you guys do this yesterday, too?
所以我就说，我要牛排法士达。她就说，我也是。然后我就想，我们真他妈是失败者。这太疯狂了。我们不能这么做。这形象太差了。这确实会让你看起来像个无趣的混蛋。就像：嘿，你们昨天也这么干的吗？
Clowns. I'm going to sewer myself on this topic. You know what I do a lot? And like, listen, I don't do it intentionally, but Alice and I will go somewhere. She'll get something. I'll get something. And like, I just inferred it's something I really want. And Alice will take a bite of hers and she'll go, oh, this is so good.
小丑。我得在这个话题上自毁长城了。你知道我经常做什么吗？而且，听着，我不是故意的，但爱丽丝和我去某个地方。她点一样，我点一样。而且，我就认定那是我想吃的东西。然后爱丽丝会咬一口她自己的，然后说，哦，这个太好吃了。
Do you want to try it? And I'm like, no. I don't. And then, like, like, I don't. like I know because she is a functioning member of society. She is waiting for me to be like, would you like to try mine? But I'm like, I like to afford this. I can't open this door.
你想尝尝吗？然后我说，不。我不想。然后，就像，我不。就像我知道，因为她是一个正常的社会成员，她在等我说：“你想尝尝我的吗？”但我心里想：我很想独自享用这一切。所以我不会主动提出来。但这就显得我很混蛋。我不会主动说：“你想尝尝这个吗？”但每当这种苗头出现时，我就想，我太清楚接下来会怎么发展了。而我就是这么个自私的混蛋。是的。我是说，有时候就像，如果有人问：“你想咬一口我的三明治吗？”
Genuinely, I'm like, I would like to eat all of this. So I'm not going to offer it. But like I'm an asshole. I'm not like, would you like to try this? But it's like every time it starts to happen, I'm like, I know how this is going to go. And I'm just such a piece of you. Yeah. I mean, sometimes it's like, if somebody's like, you want to try a bite on my sandwich?
除非我和那个人结婚了，否则我大概会说：不。我才不想把我的嘴放进你刚才放过嘴的地方，然后上面还粘着黏糊糊的洋葱皮，随着你咀嚼掉下来，然后我又在吃那个东西。我觉得我挺好的，老兄，我不需要吃你的一大口三明治。老兄说得太对了，而且我觉得在分享食物时有很多潜规则，如果是一起用叉子，如果就像是“尝一口我的菜”，那可以；但如果是一半对半分，我可就不知道了……这简直是在挑战我们关于“双重蘸酱”的话题。
Unless I'm like married to that person, I'm kind of like, no. I don't want to put my mouth where your mouth. was and like have the slimy like onion come up peel away as you're eating it and then i'm eating that same thing i'm like i'm good man i don't need a bite of your sandwich dude is so correct and i think there's there there's a lot of etiquette that gets thrown around in the in the sharing if it's a fork situation if it's like have a bite of my meal to try yes splitting one in half though i don't know about yeah yeah this this is kind of bumping up against our uh Double-dibbing conversation.
不过我好像没怎么想过，这倒是个好点子。咬一口别人的三明治，你真的是在深入接触。哦，对，那比双重蘸酱还糟糕。那更糟糕。你们在芝加哥吃过热的湿牛肉三明治吗？哦，是的。所以我和我妻子在约会时，我们曾一起跨国旅行。我觉得能够安心结婚的原因之一，或者说是因为……
But I guess I've not really thought about, that's a good point. Like, taking a bite of someone's sandwich is, you are getting really. Oh, yeah, that's worse than double-dip. That's worse. Have you guys ever had a hot wet beef sandwich in Chicago? Oh, yeah. So my wife and I, when we were, like, dating, we were traveling cross-country. And one of the reasons I felt comfortable enough to get married to, or is that, like,
我们俩一起分吃了一个湿浸牛肉三明治？我就想，好吧，我想我们大概可以结婚了。是的，我结婚了。我们一起分享了肉汁。是的，就像我们肯定得结婚了。是的。肉汁都顺着你的下巴流下来，然后你会想：我在哪儿？
we both shared a wet-dipped beef sandwich together? And I'm like, all right, I guess we can get married. Yeah, I got married. We've shared a ju. Yeah, like we certainly have to get married. Yeah. You've got the juve down your chin and you're like, where am I?
好吧。你还有什么？好吧。我的欺诈观察是这个该死的超级厄尔尼诺。这到底是怎么回事？哇，老兄。是的。我之前不在，老兄。
Okay. And what are you done? Okay. My fraud watch is this fucking Super El Nino. What is going on? Whoa, dude. Yeah. And I had been away, dude.
我刚一回来，迎面就被它扇了一巴掌。我都不知道这是怎么发生的。我刚下飞机，整个人都快窒息了。这有点像……我只是感到很迷惑，为什么感觉每隔几年……就像我们过去几年里经历了更多的厄尔尼诺。就像……97年有过一次。老兄，那是……我正想说。有没有第一次……这简直就像，这简直就像气候变暖一样。
I came right back and got hit in the face with it. I didn't know what this was happening. I got off the plane, I was suffocated. This is sort of like a, I'm just like baffled as to why it's like every couple. Like we've had like more El Nino's in the past few years. Like the, like there was one in 97. Dude, was that, I was just what to say. Was there a first, it's almost like, it's almost like climate changes.
我知道。是的，太对了。但……那个，97年有过一次。然后他们说还有一些较小的，比如2020年、2023年。而现在我们正经历着这个超级厄尔尼诺。哇。我不知道你们有没有注意到，但是更多的蚊子正涌向南加州。这他妈太糟糕了。
I know. Yeah, it's so true. But the, the, um, there was one in 97. Then they said there was like a couple smaller ones like 20, 20, 20, 23. And now we're having in this like super one. Whoa. And I don't know if you've noticed, but like more mosquitoes are coming to Southern California. Fucking sucks.
所以我有点把“超级厄尔尼诺”和“蚊子”统统归为可以滚蛋的类别。蚊子对谁都没有半点好处。比尔·盖茨不是曾试图消灭蚊子之类的吗？为了……拜托，比尔。老兄，你有一万亿美元。它们对青蛙有好处。它们对青蛙有好处吗？是的，但它们对疟疾有害。
So I'm kind of like all encompassing like Super El Nino and mosquitoes can fuck right off. Mosquitoes are literally good for nobody. Like wasn't Bill Gates trying to eradicate mosquitoes or something? Like for, like, come on, Bill. Dude, you have a trillion dollars. They're good for the frogs. Are they good for the frogs? Yeah, but they're bad for malaria.
去他的青蛙。老兄，这太潮湿了。是的。洛杉矶变得潮湿……这在我有生以来还是第一次，虽然这是个蓝色城市，但我也很喜欢听你这么说，而且看着你在录音室里穿着运动衫冻得发抖的样子。这天气太冷了，是的。老兄，我记得的第一个厄尔尼诺……我记得90年代的那股狂潮……厄尔尼诺，我只记得克里斯·法利在周六夜现场的小品，他在里面说：“厄尔尼诺就是西班牙语里的小男孩……”
Fuck the frogs. Dude, it's humidity. Yeah. It's humid in L.A. for the first. time in my life living there and it's it's it's it's blue town but I also love hearing this from you and looking at you right now in the studio wearing a sweats freezing it is cold yeah yeah dude the first i thought i remembered the first el nino i remember like i remember the craze in like the nineties like el nino i just remember the chris farley s and l satchette where he goes el nino means the nino
就像，我小时候只记得这个。老兄，有史以来第一个被记录的厄尔尼诺是在1578年，当时我就想：什么？是的。我们已经经历厄尔尼诺好几百年了，老兄。大家都冷静点。我知道。这只是让我觉得很沮丧，因为当我搬到加州时，这里很干燥，相对而言……你知道的，不会变得极其炎热，但这个天气实在是太糟糕了。我就想，让这个厄尔尼诺……
like that's all i remember as a kid dude the first historically recorded el nino was in 1578 and i'm like what? Yeah. We've been Ninoing for hundreds of years, dude. Everybody calmed out. I know. It's just like, it just bums me out because when I moved to California, it was dry, relatively well, like, you know, wasn't, didn't get incredibly hot, but this just sucked so much. I'm like, get this El Nino
滚开吧。滚开，老兄。滚开。而且显然我们二月份还要下一屁股的雨。是的，是的，没错。也许吧。是的，就像针对蚊子的历史级暴雨。确实如此。但你可能会在车里遭遇泥石流什么的。抱歉了，马里布。是的，是的。可能会发生这样的事，比如：哦，因为基础设施太烂，路塌了。我们失败了。但我只想说我不喜欢……
out of it. Get out of here, dude. Get out of here. And apparently we're going to get a buttload of rain in February. Yeah, yeah, right. Maybe. Yeah, like historic fucking gas for skisos. It's true. It is. But you might get a landslide in. your car or something. Sorry, Malibu. Yeah, yeah. Something might happen where like, oh, the road has caved in because the infrastructure sucks. We failed. But all I'm saying is I don't like, I mean,
它没有佐治亚州那么潮湿。我们可没有新奥尔良那么潮湿。老兄，当你回去的时候，你会想：哦，对啊。是的，那个糟糕得多。但这依然让人觉得：拜托，各位。没错。我跟你一样，老兄。请把我的房租降下来，好吗。是的。这可不是我想要的。如果虫子开始变多，生活成本最好开始下降。这就是我想说的。我和你同感，兄弟。滚一边去吧，超级厄尔尼诺。绝对的。我喜欢这个。
it's not as humid as like Georgia. We're not like New Orleans humid. Dude, when you go back, you're like, oh yeah. Yeah, that's way worse. But this still is kind of like, come on guys. Yep. I'm with you, dude. Lower my rent, please. Yeah. It's not what I sign up for. Cost of living better start going down if we start if the bugs start going out. That's what I'm saying. I'm with you on that, bro. Fuck right up, Super El Niño. For sure. I love it.
你是个骗子，我恨你。丹，你到底在兴奋什么？是的。不，好吧，这个可不是让我兴奋的那个。我要先做个铺垫，这跟认识的任何人都没有关系。这和任何……明显的谎言。不。
You're a fraud and I hate you. Dan, what are you so excited about? Yeah. No, well, this is not the one I'm excited about. I'm going to preface this by saying this has nothing to do with anyone that I know. This is not related to any. Clear lie. No.
不。这和任何我认识的人都没关系。我把话说在前面。我在某个航班上看着一部浪漫喜剧……然后这事出来了，我的欺诈观察是：当你的朋友们的另一半是个混蛋时，却不告诉他们。哦，哇。重磅，绝对重磅的欺诈观察。这是一个艰难的话题。
No. This has nothing to do with anyone I know. I'm getting ahead of the story. I was watching a rom-com on one of my flights. this came up, my fraud watch is not telling your friends when their significant other is ass. Oh, wow. Heavy, heavy fraud watch. That's a hard one.
没错，这确实是个艰难的话题。但你又说对了。老兄，我们居然接受了这样一种社会现象：当你的朋友——无论是女朋友在和一个势利眼、失败的家伙交往，还是男友在和一个糟糕的女孩交往——大家的普遍反应往往是：老兄，这话说出来太尴尬了。有时候你得让人们自己去弄清楚状况，巴拉巴拉巴拉。这全都是场面话，其实只是因为你不想跟一个你认识并喜爱的人进行一次艰难的对话，而你认识并喜爱这个朋友的时间，可远比那个所谓的另一半要长得多。所以，老兄，我们得开始挺身而出了。我们得开始拯救我们的朋友了。
Yep, it is a hard one. But you're right again. It, dude, it is insane that we accept a society when you're, when your friend, whether it be a girlfriend, dating a douche, loser guy, whether it be a guy friend, dating a bad gal, going. the generic response is, dude, it's just such an uncomfortable conversation. Sometimes you've got to let people figure things out for themselves, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. That's just all lip service for you not wanting to have a hard conversation with someone that you know and love and have known in love for much longer than this other significant other person. So it's like, dude, we got to start stepping up to the plate. We've got to start saving our friends.
《拯救西尔弗曼》。哇，真是一部他妈的好电影。那简直就是我真正想看的电影。是的，是的。是的。字面意义上，这就是我看的电影。我当时一边看一边笑。然后我觉得，这真是一件既搞笑又让人感同身受的事。
Saving Silverman. Wow, what a fucking movie. That's literally the movie I won't actually. Yeah, yeah. Yes. Literally, that's the movie that I watched. And I was watching it and I was laughing. And I was like, this is such a funny, you know, relatable thing.
但它能让人感同身受，本身就说明这是一个问题。这结局是她其实挺酷的吗？还是她真的很坏？不，她是个精神病患者，但她最后和史蒂夫·扎恩在一起了，因为史蒂夫·扎恩也是个精神病患者。当她在电影里把一大块巨无霸酱汁滴到胸上时，我真的很喜欢。你能别再像个13岁的发情小屁孩了吗？他当时13岁。我猜吧。
But the fact that it's relatable should be the tell that this is a problem. Does that end with her being kind of cool? Or she is bad. No, she's a psychopath, but she ends up with Steve Zahn because Steve Zon is also a psychopath. When she drops a big mac sauce on her boobs in that movie, I really enjoyed it. Can you be less of a 13-year-old fuck? He was 13. I guess.
我只是在表达我13岁时的感受。我说我看到那一幕时真的很喜欢。我只想说这个。是的，但我正试图就我的欺诈观察进行一次严肃的对话，而你却直接扯到13岁发情的CP身上，你这个失败的混蛋。你勾起了我一些美好的回忆。保持专注一秒钟。我认为，如果我们作为一个社会能够更多地挺身而出、开始拯救我们的朋友，这种现象就不会成为一种普遍的叙事。
Just telling you how I felt about 13. I said when I saw that, I really enjoyed it. That's all I'm saying. Yeah, but I'm trying to have a serious conversation about my fraud watch and you just go to 13-year-old horny CP, you fucking loser. You brought back some good memories. Stay focused for one second. I think that this would be less of a narrative if we as a society stepped up more and started saving our friends. This should not be a thing that people relate to.
这本不该是人们能感同身受的事。因为，你知道的，这种事越普遍，那场艰难的对话其实就越不困难。因为如果你的朋友对你说：嘿，顺便说一句，你的另一半太烂了，你可以找到更好的人。这现在应该变成一件很正常的事。然后他们会说：哦，哇，我已经听过好多次了。这事一直在发生。那肯定是真的。对不舒服的对话的恐惧，或者对生活中不舒服的对话的抗拒，本身就应该上欺诈观察，丹。我们应该随时进行那些有帮助的不舒服的对话。
It should be because, you know, the more common place it gets, the less difficult the conversation is. Because if your friend goes like this, hey, by the way, your significant other stinks, you can do way better. That is now a normal thing. And they go, oh, wow, I've heard that. This is happening all the time. It must be true. The normalizing or being afraid of uncomfortable conversations in general is on fraud botched, Dan. We should be having uncomfortable conversations that are helpful all the time.
沟通是关键。绝对的。沟通是关键。我只是……听听，我站在“拯救你的朋友”这一队。你的朋友对你而言意味着整个世界。当你看到你的某个女性朋友被某个混蛋男人给吸干了心力，而你却只是说“她得自己吸取教训”，这感觉太糟糕了。我的想法是：要么我们去帮帮忙，要么我来当英雄。这他妈的算怎么回事？我觉得我们得……
Communication is key. Absolutely. Communication is key. And I just, listen, I'm just on team, save your friends. Your friends mean the world to you. And it stinks when you see, like, you know, one, of your girlfriends just like get sucked in by some douche guy and you just go like this she's got to learn on her own. I'm like, or we can help. Or I can be the hero. Like what the fuck? I think we got to
开始拨乱反正。对吧。因为现在报信的人左右挨枪。现在。是的，克里斯。我们在拯救信使。保护我们的死党。保护我们的信使。我喜欢这样，老兄。你想来个蛇形选秀加入你的……加入你的选秀吗？是的，我当然想。我要进行蛇形选秀，伙计们，我对这个兴奋极了。我本周的热门点击是番茄酱。天哪。哦，就像男人的皮特胸前那种酱？是的。
start up right. Right. Because right now you're getting messengers getting killed left and right now. Nowadays. Yeah, Chris. We're saving the message. Protect our buddies. Protect our messengers. I love it, dude. Do you want a snake draft into your into your, yeah. I sure do. I'm going to snake draft into mine and fellas, I am I am jazzed about this one. My top hit this week is ketchup. Oh my God. Oh, like the kind on a man of Pete's boobs? Yeah.
那是大混乱。好吧，那种酱里有番茄酱，丹。你最好相信这一点。它带有一种橙色的色调。如果我提到了13岁的小屁孩，对，我记得。我能完美地想象出来。那种酱带有一点橙色。
That's big mess. Well, there's ketchup in that sauce, Dan. You better believe that. There's an orange tinge. If I called on 13-year-old, yeah, I remember it. I can see it perfectly. There's an orange tinge to that sauce.
埃文，我太需要你加入我的战队了。结果你又把话题扯偏了。我的热门点击是番茄酱。这太糟糕了。我就知道你会这么说。但听我解释，先生。番茄酱是黄金标准的经典调味品，你知道吗？这就是为什么番茄酱是我的热门点击，因为我相信番茄酱值得更多的尊重。好吧。番茄酱一直被贬低，一直被嫌弃。你会听到很多人在谈论热狗、香肠时会说：
Evan, I needed you on my team here so bad. And now you've got them off topic again. My top hit is ketchup. This is terrible. I knew you would say that. but hear me out sir ketchup is a gold standard staple and you know what this is why ketchup is my top hit because i believe that ketchup deserves more respect okay ketchup is constantly dismissed constantly shit on you'll hear a lot of people when it comes to dogs broths sausages they'll be like
老兄，如果你在热狗上加番茄酱，你就是个他妈的小孩。这感觉就像是，放松点，兄弟。如果有人喜欢番茄酱，就让他加呗。这很有趣，因为我也经常这么说，但同时你是对的。这里是我的第一点，好吧？让我们想想其他受欢迎的调味品。我们来谈谈烧烤酱。
dude, if you put ketchup on a dog, you're a fucking child. And it's kind of like, relax, man. Like if someone likes ketchup, let him put it on there. It's funny because I do say that, but also you're right. Yeah. Here is my number one point, okay? Let's think about some other popular condiments. Let's talk about barbecue sauce.
是的，不可思议。我们来谈谈芥末酱。不可思议。我们来谈谈蛋黄酱。不可思议。这三种调味品之所以出名，是因为什么？
Yeah, incredible. Let's talk about mustard. Incredible. Let's talk about mayo. Incredible. All three of those condiments are famous. for what? They're variations. You've got spicy barbecue. You've got hickory barbecue. You've got barbecue, honey barbecue. Mustard. You've got spicy brown. You've got multi-grain. You've got
它们的变体。你有辣味烧烤酱。你有山核桃烧烤酱。你有烧烤酱、蜂蜜烧烤酱。芥末酱。你有辣味棕芥末。你有全麦芥末。你有……
honey mustard. You've got everything. Dejean. Mayo, you've got garlic aoli. You've got like jalapeno, blah, blah, blah. All of these different iterations and variations. And don't get me wrong. I love those two. They're great. But you know what you never see a variation on is ketchup. And the one time that three or four year period where the bougie stuck up restaurant industry tried to do it, they tried to institute some like spicy ketchup. It was Chipotle ketchup.
蜂蜜芥末酱。你有什么都有。第戎芥末。蛋黄酱，你有大蒜蛋黄酱。你有诸如墨西哥辣椒味之类乱七八糟的。所有这些不同的迭代和变体。别误会我。我也很喜欢那些。它们都很棒。但你知道你永远不会看到有变体的调味品是什么吗？就是番茄酱。而在那三四年的时间里，那些装腔作势的餐饮业试图推出这种东西时，他们曾试图引入某种辣味番茄酱。那是墨西哥奇波雷辣椒番茄酱。
It was it? Yeah, and I actually liked it though. Really? I don't even know like fucking remember this. Kevin, shut up and let me cook. All of those things, boom, kicked out the fucking door after a few years because the ketchup industry went, you know what, dude, these things suck. If you were one of those loser, L7 weenie restaurants that Evan was getting hard at because they had Chipotle ketchup, they eventually got booted out the door because people went, I just want
是吗？是的，而且其实我还挺喜欢的。真的吗？我甚至都不知道……他妈的还记得这个。凯文，闭嘴，让我发挥。所有这些东西，砰，几年后都被踢出局了，因为番茄酱行业心想：你知道吗，老兄，这些东西太烂了。如果你是埃文刚才因为有奇波雷辣椒番茄酱而兴奋得不行的那些失败餐厅之一，你最终会被赶出门去，因为人们会去说：我只想……
fucking Heinz tomato ketchup with my fucking French fries. Get all of your fancy ketchup out of my face and bring back the classic. And that happened. You never see that nonsense anymore. People just want their ketchup because it's perfect as it is. Ketchup did not need variations. It did not need alterations because ketchup rocks and ketchup people knew that from day one. Dude, that, I have a, if this was a debate, if this was the old school Will Farrell, what's that guy's name with the bald head? James Carvel, dude, the Raging Cajun.
在我的法式炸薯条上配亨利番茄酱。把我脸前的那些花哨番茄酱全拿走，把经典款拿回来。然后事情确实就变成了那样。你再也看不到那种无聊的东西了。人们只想要他们的番茄酱，因为它本身就已经完美了。番茄酱不需要变体，不需要篡改，因为番茄酱棒极了，喜欢番茄酱的人从第一天起就知道这一点。老兄，如果这是一场辩论，如果这是老派的威尔·法瑞尔……那个光头叫什么名字？詹姆斯·卡维尔，老兄，愤怒的卡琼人。
If this was a debate, my team would have a prepared response, which I will say, I mean, briefly articulate, but I just want to say that that was an incredible. logic take. Like, I have a, I have a, a rebuttal. It was inspirational. Yeah. Because it's, it's,
如果这是一场辩论，我的团队会准备好回应，我稍后会说，我的意思是，简要阐述一下，但我只想说那是一个不可思议的逻辑观点。就像，我有一个反驳。这太鼓舞人心了。因为，它……
everything you said is right. My rebuttal, or go ahead. I'm sick of it, God. No, I was just gonna, I'm sick of it. I'm sick of the, I'm sick of the ketchup slander.
你所说的一切都是对的。我的反驳是……或者你先说，天哪，我受够了。不，我只是想说，我受够了。我受够了。我受够了对番茄酱的诽谤。
Because like, listen, if you're not a ketchup person, that's fine, but that's your problem. ketchup is incredible. And like, I'm sorry, dude. It is rare when you see a food like a French fry,
因为，听着，如果你不是一个番茄酱爱好者，那没关系，但这那是你的问题。番茄酱太不可思议了。而且，抱歉，老兄。当看到像炸薯条这样的食物时，这太罕见了……
for example, that is so universal. I know there's some mayo people, and that's cool, but it is so universally, like if you ask a kid to, we talk about the Ferrari thing all the time, Chris, you ask a kid to draw a race car, they will color it red. If you ask a kid to draw a plate of French fries, they will put ketchup on it. Totally correct. I think that the rebuttal take is ketchup. And you're going to disagree this, but it is largely true. Ketchup is much more popular in a younger demographic. Like ketchup is a is a younger palate taste. And I think all. these variations apply to adult palettes. Like I an adult want Dijon. I'm like, ooh, this is now good because I'm not older. Kids, if you Dijon ketchup, like a six-year-old is like, this is horrible. And adults who might like a Dijon ketchup like you, like me grew out of ketchup a while ago. So I'm like, I don't need this, whatever. Like, I moved on. And may I respond? It was not long ago on this pod where we were discussing Peebee and J's and Mac and Cheese.
比如，它是如此普遍。我知道有一些蛋黄酱爱好者，这很酷，但它是如此普遍地……如果你让一个孩子去画画，我们一直在谈论法拉利的事情，克里斯，如果你让一个孩子画一辆赛车，他们会把它涂成红色。如果你让一个孩子画一盘炸薯条，他们会在上面挤上番茄酱。完全正确。我认为反驳的观点是番茄酱。你可能会不同意这一点，但这在很大程度上是事实。番茄酱在年轻群体中更受欢迎。番茄酱是一种偏向年轻人的口味。而且我认为所有……这些变体都适用于成年人的口味。比如我作为一个成年人，我想要第戎芥末酱。我会想：哦，这个现在很好，因为我不再年轻了。小孩子们，如果你在番茄酱里加第戎芥末，比如一个六岁的孩子会觉得：这太难吃了。而那些可能喜欢第戎番茄酱的成年人，像你，像我，很久以前就已经不再喜欢番茄酱了。所以我心想：我不需要这个，随便啦。比如，我已经向前看了。我能回应吗？不久前在这个播客上，我们还在讨论花生酱果酱三明治和通心粉加奶酪。
Yeah, correct. And this is my point. Just because something was good when you were a kid doesn't mean it's not good still. Dude, and yeah. And I really don't like how people like, I mean, I'm like, I don't really like PB&J because I like other stuff. But the reality is, dude, I still like French fries. I still like a grilled cheese and I want to dip that shit. Bro, ketchup, as you know, I don't really like ketchup. But there is something about fries.
没错，对吧。这就是我的观点。不能因为某样东西你在小时候觉得好，就代表它现在不好了。老兄，真的是这样。而且我真的很讨厌那种人，就是，我觉得吧，我其实不太喜欢花生酱果酱三明治，因为我喜欢别的东西。但现实是，老兄，我还是喜欢炸薯条。我还是喜欢烤奶酪三明治，而且我想蘸着吃。兄弟，番茄酱，如你所知，我其实不太喜欢番茄酱。但薯条这东西很奇妙。
Like French fries and ketchup is really good. And I don't, if I put ketchup on other things I like, I kind of don't like the bite. anymore but for eyes for whatever reason i'm like no this is the this is the correct flavor palette to make this try good i so dude top top hit ketchup i've got something to say to dan and as a proud pittsburger hinds field you know hinds's britain so this is my home stuff yeah and i love ketchup lately in my life i have found that the ultra-processed sort of chemically taste of it i'm like if you could give me like homemade ketchup yeah i'd probably fucking love it Yeah. And I'm saying this is a Pittsburgh guy.
就像炸薯条配番茄酱真的很好吃。而且我不，如果我把番茄酱加到其他我喜欢的东西上，我可能就不太喜欢那种口感了。但不知为什么，对于薯条，我会觉得不，这才是，这才是让这个薯条好吃的正确风味搭配。所以我，老兄，最爱番茄酱，我有话要对丹说，作为一个骄傲的匹兹堡人，亨氏球场，你知道的，亨氏是英国的，所以这是我的家乡特产，对吧，我超爱番茄酱。最近在我的生活中，我发现那种超级加工的、带有某种化学味的东西，我就想，如果你能给我那种自制番茄酱，对吧，我他妈肯定超爱。没错。我是以一个匹兹堡人的身份这么说的。
Yeah, Heinz coming for you. The regular bottle of like ketchup with like a billion chemical ingredients, I'm always like, don't know if I need it. But if I'm like hanging out and eating unhealthy shit, it doesn't matter. So I will say that as Evelyn Beatrice Hall said, I may not agree with what you say, but I will defend to the death you're right to say it. Yeah. So I completely agree with your point, even though I may sometimes find ketchup to be like. Dan, you should, Dan, you should make,
没错，亨氏来找你了。那种含有几十亿种化学成分的普通瓶装番茄酱，我总是觉得，不知道自己是不是需要它。但如果我在闲逛，吃着不健康的垃圾食品，那倒无所谓。所以我得说，正如伊芙琳·比阿特丽斯·霍尔所说，我可能不同意你说的每一个字，但我誓死捍卫你说话的权利。对吧。所以我完全同意你的观点，尽管我有时可能会觉得番茄酱有点……丹，你应该，丹，你应该做个……
you should try to make a homemade ketchup once. Like, get some, get some, like, try to broke tomatoes again. Like, I don't know if your balcony has enough sun, but, like, that would be cool if you had a many veggie garden and then made your own homemade ketchup. What is it? Just like tomato. I don't know.
你真该试着自己做一次番茄酱。比如，弄点，弄点，试着再种种西红柿。就是，我不知道你阳台上的阳光够不够，但是，如果你能有一个小菜园，然后自己做番茄酱，那就太酷了。那是什么？就番茄吗？我不知道。
I have no idea, but, yeah, it can't be that hard. Yeah. That'd be sick. B vinegar, yeah. Okay, Dan, that would be gas up now. That really, excellent work, Dan. Okay, Ev, what do you got? Thank you, gentlemen.
我完全不知道，不过，对吧，应该没那么难。对吧。那太酷了。加点醋，对吧。好吧，丹，现在听起来太赞了。那真的，干得漂亮，丹。好吧，伊夫，你有什么？谢谢你们，各位。
Similar in the food vein, but also completely hypocritical to what I just said. I love movie theater popcorn. Oh, dude, same. It's fucking unbelievable. This guy's talking to me about chemicals and he's putting movie theater pop-upers. Are you buttering, though? Are you buttering, Evan?
虽然跟食物有关，但也完全违背了我刚才说的话。我超爱电影院的爆米花。哦，老兄，我也是。太他妈棒了。这家伙跟我谈化学成分，结果他自己却在吃电影院的爆米花。不过你加黄油了吗？你加黄油了吗，埃文？
You know he is. Look at him. Okay, because I used to be, I used to be layered butter. Like, I'd be like, hey, layer it the butter in so I can get it everywhere. And now it is. Chris is like putting a straw in the bucket and dumping the butter straight down the straw. So, yeah, to make myself a complete hypocritical asshole, like the smell that chemically smell when you hit the movie theater it is like fucking crap
你知道他肯定加了。看他那样。好吧，因为我以前是，我以前喜欢分层加黄油。就像，我会说，嘿，帮我把黄油一层层加进去，这样每个地方都能沾到。而现在呢。克里斯就像是把一根吸管插进桶里，然后把黄油顺着吸管直接倒到底。所以，好吧，为了让自己变成一个彻头彻尾虚伪的混蛋，当走进电影院时闻到的那种味道，那种化学气味，简直就像他妈的垃圾……
it is incredible and even when I go in and I'm like you know what I'm going to see schindler's list I'm not going to be munching on popcorn drinking a fucking leader of cola yeah but that smell hits me and I'm like large popcorn yeah yeah every time dude I literally go in I've I've recently told someone that it's like in casinos where they pump in oxygen I will go into a movie theater and I smell, I will go into a movie theater after being at Fogo to Chow, having a full all you can eat dinner with zero space in my stomach and I will order popcorn. So I think it's an addiction. It's a problem. But I used to work at the Arklight movie theater, rest in peace. So this was like, people that don't know this, this was like sort of a SoCal
这简直绝了，哪怕当我走进去，心想，你知道吗，我是来看《辛德勒的名单》的，我才不会一边嚼着爆米花一边喝着他妈的一升可乐，对吧，但那种香味一飘过来，我就想，来个大桶爆米花。对，对，每次都这样，老兄，我真的走进去，我最近才跟人说过，这就跟赌场里 pumping 氧气一样，我走进电影院时闻到那味儿，我哪怕刚在 Fogo de Chão 吃完一顿全美式自助大餐，肚子撑得一点空隙都没有，我还是会点爆米花。所以我猜这是一种瘾。这是个问题。但我以前在 Arclight 电影院工作过，愿它安息。所以，对于不了解的人来说，这就像是南加州的一种……
it was my first job in L.A. when I was like 22. And we used real butter. Yeah, wow. So they, so you would have to heat the, the butter would be in a heated tin. So it wasn't like chemically butter. So the butter would go in hard and you had to let it get liquefied. But people would ask us, they'd be like fill it up halfway, pump some butter, put a little more in, pump some butter. So I, but I rarely get butter because I'm like, I don't need those chemicals. Exactly now we just can't.
这是我在洛杉矶的第的一份工作，当时我大概22岁。而且我们用的是真黄油。没错，哇。所以他们，所以你必须把，黄油放在一个加热的金属盒里。所以它不是那种化学黄油。所以黄油放进去时是硬的，你得把它化成液体。但人们会要求我们，他们会说，装满一半，按几下黄油，再装一点，再按几下黄油。所以，我，但我很少加黄油，因为我觉得，我不需要那些化学成分。确实，现在我们真的不能了。
But if I'm having a real fuck it day, if it's like a Saturday and I've just had a week, I'm like, I want to put some butter on that. Yeah, dude. And I have gone the arc light in Culver, we used to live by there. Yeah. There have been times in my life. Actually, it's kind of bad. It's not an arc lane anymore, but the theater's there.
但如果我今天真的想放纵一下，如果是个周六，我刚熬过艰难的一周，我就会想，我一定要在那上面加点黄油。对啊，老兄。我去过卡尔弗城的 Arclight，我们以前就住在附近。对吧。我生命中有过好几次。其实，这有点糟。它现在已经不是 Arclight 了，但电影院还在那里。
again. Anyway, I would go, if we were watching a movie that we were renting at home on our big screen, I would go to the Culver Theater and buy popcorn and then just bring it back to the house. And we would eat the Culver movie theater popcorn at home. That is so dope. That's how good this is. We like during COVID, my, uh, I got a projector because I missed going to the movies. I got like a nice projector. And I was sitting there going like, ah, you know, I just really miss movie theater popcorn. So for my birthday, my wife, she was my girlfriend then, bought me like a movie theater. I've seen those.
总之，我会去，如果我们当时在家里的大屏幕上租了一部电影看，我会去卡尔弗电影院买爆米花，然后把它带回屋里。我们会在家里吃卡尔弗电影院的爆米花。这太酷了。这就是它有多好吃。我们在新冠疫情期间，我的，呃，我买了一个投影仪，因为我很想去电影院。我买了一个很好的投影仪。然后我就坐在那儿想，啊，你知道的，我真的好想念电影院的爆米花。所以为了我的生日，我太太——她当时还是我女朋友——给我买了一个电影院级别的爆米花机。我见过那种。
Not like the huge, huge ones, but like a pretty good size one. And it was supposed to be a surprise. And it showed up in a box on our door. And like it was one of those like boxes where they don't really put it in a box. It's just like the box says popcorn maker. And she's like, well, surprise. Happy birthday. Happy fucking birthday.
不是那种超级无敌大的，但尺寸也相当不错。本来应该是个惊喜。然后它就作为一个箱子出现在我们的门廊上。就像那种根本不装在外盒里，箱子上直接印着“爆米花机”的快递箱。她就说，好吧，惊喜。生日快乐。祝你他妈的生日快乐。
That's awesome. Do you still have it? Oh, yeah. Yeah. I like brought it to people's parties. And if they're doing screenings, I'll like, I'll bring my popcorn maker if you want. And it's good as hell. That's fucking great.
太棒了。你现在还有吗？哦，对。对。我甚至把它带到别人的派对上。如果他们要办放映会，我就会，我会把我的爆米花机带过去，如果你想要的话。而且它好吃得要命。太他妈棒了。
We had one for a while then. Remember? That was a small one. Yeah. Yeah. It's just to clean. Yeah. Oh, yeah.
我们曾经也有过一个，对吧？记得吗？那个小型的。对。对。只是太难清洗了。对，没错。
It's a process. Okay. Two really good ones here. Mine is way more low key, but I think we'll still hit. My top hit is long phone chargers. I remember getting one of them. And I was like, oh, this is such a luxury. And then the other day I was like, I'm just going to buy like five of these.
这绝对是个大麻烦。好了，这里有两个非常棒的。我的要低调得多，但我觉得依然会很实用。我最推荐的是长手机充电线。我记得我第一次买到这种线的时候。当时我就想，哇，这也太奢侈了吧。然后前几天我就想，我干脆买个五条这种线算了。
I'm going to replace all my phone chargers that are scattered around my house with the long ones. So now there's a long one by my bed. There's a long one in the living room. You know, there's a long one by Sandra. And now it's just like, there's no issue. My phone is charging. I have to check something. I got to show her.
我要用长充电线把我家里散落的所有手机充电器都换掉。所以现在我的床头有一根长的。客厅里有一根长的。你知道的，桑德拉旁边也有一根长的。现在感觉就是，完全没有问题了。我的手机在充电。我需要查点东西。我得给她看。
Boom, it's still plugged in. The living room, it reaches all the way across to the other seat that she's in. I cannot believe we were ever selling, I don't know, you can't believe we even sell regular-sized phone charges anymore. Like, why? Maybe we'll get to the point where they're like a dog leash. You know, they like zip out and they'll zip back in. But having a short phone charger is insane these days. Like, what are you possibly doing?
轰，它还连着线。在客厅里，它一直延伸到她坐着的另一张椅子上。我简直不敢相信我们以前居然还在卖，我不知道，你简直不敢相信我们现在居然还在卖标准长度的手机充电器。就像，为什么？也许以后我们会发展到像狗绳一样的那种程度。你知道的，它们可以抽拉出来，还能自动缩回去。但如今用短手机充电器简直太疯狂了。你到底在干什么？
Dude, I was right about to say the fact that non-long ones even exist anymore is insane. But then you just blew my cock off my body with the fucking dog leash version. It's already a little block. It's a little bit. That'd be incredible. Why don't we should delete this? Evan, delete this. Delete all this.
老兄，我正想说，现在居然还有非加长版的充电器存在，这本身就很疯狂。但你刚刚抛出的那个“狗绳版”的想法直接把我整个人惊呆了。这已经是个小段子了。这太不可思议了。我们为什么不把这段删掉？埃文，把这段删了。把这些全删了。
Oh, so we're going to make some money? Yeah. We're going to invent that. The letters long charge. It's incredible, dude. Yeah, the long change, Dan. We'll call it the long change. Yeah.
哦，所以我们要赚钱了？对。我们要发明那个东西。就叫长充电线。这太不可思议了，老兄。对，长充电线，丹。我们就叫它“长充电线”。对。
Oh, my God. The netter's long change. Second period long charge. crack. Yeah, brother. They're amazing. Genius. Genius top hit.
天哪。“内特长充电线”。绝对是个天才点子。天才级的顶级推荐。
They're incredible. I have them all over my house as well, and they are necessary. Just not having one. Absolutely, dude. Crazy. And like when you go to an Airbnb and you're like, oh, I only have my short charger. Now I have to, like, lean 15 feet over my bed to look at my phone. Truly.
它们太不可思议了。我家里到处都是这种线，而且它们是必需品。如果没有一根的话……绝对的，老兄。太疯狂了。就像当你去 Airbnb 住，然后心想，哦，我只有短充电线。现在我不得不，为了看手机，必须在床上探出15英尺远。真的。
I'm like, dude, I actually bought a box of multiple long chargers. And after day one, Gavin stole one. And I almost committed. Oh, my God. I was like, dude, anything but the long charger. Take all the shoe my eyes. Have you been to like gas stations where they sell those chargers that have like almost like a like a, like a cloth cover on. Oh, no.
我就想，老兄，我其实买了一整盒各种长充电线。结果第一天过完，加文就偷了一根。我差点就想犯罪了。天哪。当时我就想，老兄，什么都行，除了长充电线。把我的双眼拿去吧。你去过那种加油站吗？他们卖那种充电器，上面几乎带有一种，像布面材质外壳的。哦，没有。
And then like they just don't work. Like I've had experiences where you buy like, oh, phone charger, gas station. And then you plug it in and it's like this doesn't work at all. Yeah, like thanks. If you buy a phone charger at a gas station, it better be an emergency and you only need it for one day because that's as long as it will last. That is a fact. Hey, fellas, that was one of the best. That's a great round.
然后那种充电器就是根本不好用。我曾经有过这种经历，你在加油站买了一个，哦，手机充电器。然后你把它插上，结果发现这玩意儿根本不管用。对，就好像，谢谢啦。如果你在加油站买手机充电器，那最好是遇到紧急情况，而且你只需要用一天，因为那就是它能撑的极限了。这是一个事实。嘿，伙计们，这绝对是最好的一期。这是一轮超棒的。
fraud watching top hit rounds I've ever seen. We're going to take a quick ad break and then wrap things up, but that was incredible. Lucy is the official pouch partner of Almost Friday and Empty Netters. It is the best pouch in the game. We're talking premium stuff here. We're talking 100% tobacco-free nicotine pouches that are made for pouch connoisseurs, the best-feeling pouch in the world.
这是我见过的最棒的“盲品推荐”环节。我们要进行一个简短的广告插播，然后做个收尾，但刚才真的太精彩了。Lucy 是 Almost Friday 和 Empty Netters 的官方烟碱袋合作伙伴。这是业内最棒的烟碱袋。我们谈论的是优质产品。我们谈论的是100%无烟草的尼古丁袋，专为烟碱袋鉴赏家打造，是世界上手感最好的烟碱袋。
And when it comes to flavors, it's out of control. You've got the unbelievable mint, wintergreen mango. They've got an espresso. And when you get those breakers, you've got unreal stuff going on. We got the apple. We got the berry. It's just so, so incredible. And I'll tell you what, man, when it comes to what you need these nicotine pouches for, Lucy has you covered.
说到口味，简直无法无天。你有令人难以置信的薄荷、冬青、芒果。他们还有浓缩咖啡。当你尝尝那些爆珠时，你会体验到超乎想象的奇妙感受。我们有苹果口味。我们有浆果口味。简直是太、太不可思议了。我告诉你，老兄，说到你需要这些尼古丁袋的场合，Lucy 都能满足你。
Milligrams four, eight, 12. Pick whichever you like the most. If you're trying to get dialed in, focus up on some work, maybe out on the golf course, something like that. Lucy is perfect. If you're trying to wind down, have some dinner, watch a movie. Lucy is perfect as well. There's no occasion that Lucy can't take care of. you in. So what we're going to do here, folks, is we're going to get you set up. Lucy, again,
4毫克、8毫克、12毫克。选择你最喜欢的那个。如果你想集中精力工作，或者在打高尔夫球时保持专注，诸如此类。Lucy 是完美的。如果你想放松一下，吃个晚饭，看个电影。Lucy 同样是完美的。没有什么场合是 Lucy 照顾不到的。所以我们要做的就是，各位，我们要帮你们安排妥当。Lucy，再次强调，
is the only pouch that delivers long-lasting on-demand flavor. And you're going to save 20% off right now on your first order when you buy online at lucy.com slash netters with code N-E-T-T-E-R-S. If you've never bought online before, guys, here you go, 20% off. Save some money with Lucy. It's a no-brainer. Get it done today. Warning, this product contains nicotine. Nicotine is an addictive chemical. All right, let's close things out with a blind ranking, and in honor and memory of Tim Curry, we're going to do blind ranking Tim Curry rolls. Evan, what do we got?
是唯一一款能提供持久、随叫随到口感的烟碱袋。现在你在 lucy.com/netters 网上购买时，输入优惠码 N-E-T-T-E-R-S，即可在第一笔订单中立省20%。如果你以前从未在网上买过，伙计们，机会来了，立省20%。用 Lucy 省点钱。这根本不用多想。今天就行动吧。警告，本产品含有尼古丁。尼古丁是一种会让人上瘾的化学物质。好了，让我们以盲评排名来做个收尾，为了纪念伟大的蒂姆·库瑞，我们要进行蒂姆·库瑞角色盲评排名。埃文，我们有什么？
All right. The first one we're going to take a look at is Rocky Horror Picture Show, Dr. Frankenfurter. There was literally 0.0% chance that this wasn't on Evans' list. There was literally no chance. Well, it's the role that broke him out. Exactly. I knew it was coming.
好。我们要看的第一个是《洛基恐怖秀》里的法兰克·N·弗furter 博士。这绝对有0.0%的概率不会出现在埃文的名单上。这绝对没有这种可能。好吧，这是让他一炮走红的角色。没错。我就知道它会出现。
I'm actually glad it's first stand, so we didn't get shoehorned into something. Now we can make a logical, sound decision on Rocky Horror. What is your instinct? I know what yours is. Well, no, you don't. Yes, I do. You are itching in your seat to put this at five. No, but I was going to say four. But I'm afraid you're about to be like one. It's iconic, which it is. Absolutely not. Absolutely not. I really like Rocky Horror, but I'm not a nut about it. I love that it broke him out. but I'm going to say three.
我其实很高兴它是第一个，丹，这样我们就不会被迫塞进什么奇怪的角色了。现在我们可以对《洛基恐怖秀》做一个合乎逻辑、稳妥的决定。你的直觉是什么？我知道你的直觉是什么。不，你不知道。不，我知道。你屁股坐立不安，想把它放在第五位。不，但我本想说第四位。但我怕你马上要把它说成第一位。它太标志性了，确实如此。绝对不是。绝对不是。我真的很喜欢《洛基恐怖秀》，但我不是那种狂热粉丝。我很高兴它让他一炮走红。但我打算把它放在第三位。
It is so popular. And if you wanted to wrestle me, in the people that love it. It's incredible. If you wanted to wrestle me to the ground and go four, I am fine. Maybe it is a good three
它太受欢迎了。如果你想跟我争辩，在那些热爱它的人当中。这太不可思议了。如果你想把我按倒在地，非要把它排在第四位，我也完全可以接受。也许排第三确实挺合适，
due to how legendary it is. It's a legendary. Because it is that, like, oh my God. Iconic. Yeah, okay. You've actually talked to me up. It's got to tuck me up.
鉴于它有多么传奇。这是一个传奇角色。因为它就是那种，哦天哪。标志性的。好吧，好吧。你其实说服我了。你确实说服我了。
I'm going three. All right. The next one is homilin two. the hotel concierge. I mean, I mean, this is, I think a lot of,
我选第三。好吧。下一个是《小鬼当家2》里的酒店礼宾。我的意思是，我的意思是，这，我觉得很多人，
I think a lot of people see Tim Curry's face and they think of it. Dude, when he, there is like, when, when,
我觉得很多人看到蒂姆·库瑞的脸就会想到这个。老兄，当他，有一次，当，当，
uh, they're being shot at, you know, they're doing the, like, they're doing the, uh, what's that movie called again,
呃，他们正在被人开枪射击，你知道的，他们在拍那个，像他们在拍那个，那部电影叫什么来着，
Dan? Oh, angels with dirty, uh, angels with filthy souls. Yeah, they're doing like the angels of filthy souls bit, you know,
丹？哦，《独家腥闻》——不对，《天使之尘》——哦，《天使之翼》里带有粗俗灵魂的天使。对，他们在模仿《天使之翼》的那个桥段，你知道的，
and he's, he's like, they're, it's him and like the, the bell, the old bellboy, whose name is Cliff. you know and like they mentioned
然后他，他就像，他们是，是他和那个，呃，行李员，那个老行李员，名字叫克里夫，你知道的，然后他们提到，
that's Rob Schneider no no there's that he's the young there's like a really old guy in the scene oh yeah oh yeah okay and they're like in the movie they're like Cliff Cliff's gay or something and like they all look at the old guy oh yeah yeah yeah what to fuck
那是罗伯·施耐德？不，不，那是年轻的，场景里还有一个非常老的老头。哦，对，哦，对，好吧，然后在电影里他们就说，克里夫，克里夫是同性恋还是什么的，然后他们都看着那个老头。哦，对，哦，对。真他妈的好笑。
so funny um okay well we can't blow Evan's head off his body but I do think god this is kind of why I wanted to go for I think I want to go to here Dan I mean home alone too is like
太搞笑了，嗯，好吧，我们不能把埃文的脑子炸飞，但我确实觉得，天哪，这就是为什么我想选第四位。我觉得我想把它放在这里，丹。我的意思是，《小鬼当家2》简直就是，
all kind. Listen, dude, I know. I mean, like, I could go. Fuck. I'm down with two. We could go four to protect some, to protect some, like,
太经典了。听着，老兄，我知道。我的意思是，我本来可以。操。我同意排第二。我们可以把它排在第四位，以此来保护一些，保护一些可能会来喷的，
haters that could be coming. What are, what are we protecting? Guys, you don't even know. Like, I'm gonna, like, don't do bad ones. I'm not. Yeah, yeah, that's, he's not. He's not.
喷子。我们在保护什么？伙计们，你们根本不知道。就像，我会，就像，别选烂片。我不会。对，对，他不会。他绝对不会。
He's not. Don't do psycho ones that we don't know. Trust me. That's why I'm thinking, like, God, but I do love Home Alone too, though. Yeah, he does. I mean, dude, the 90s were good. Yeah, that's why I'm like, fuck, do we go?
他不会。别选那些我们根本不知道的偏门电影。相信我。这就是为什么我在想，天哪，但我确实超爱《小鬼当家2》。对，他确实爱。我的意思是，老兄，90年代的电影就是好。对，这就是为什么我在想，操，我们该选第几？
We should, yeah. That's two or four. I mean, the home alone, four. Oh, my God, dude. Yeah, you got it. I would say that's smart just because he just isn't in the movie that much. I know, I might regret this, but okay. All right, it, Pennywise, the clown.
我们应该，对。那是第二还是第四？我的意思是，《小鬼当家》，第四。哦，天哪，老兄。对，你懂的。我觉得这样很明智，因为他在电影里戏份其实没那么多。我知道，我可能会后悔，但好吧。好了，《小丑回魂》，潘尼怀斯。
Jesus Christ, dude. Did you remember that he was that fucking clown? I now do. Absolutely, dude. And I made a career when the new hits came out of being like this. Did you know that 1040 is actually the original Pennywise? that's going to be two for me. Terrifying.
耶稣基督，老兄。你还记得他就是那个该死的小丑吗？我刚刚想起来。绝对的，老兄。当新版上映时，我甚至以此为职业，到处说：你知道蒂姆·库瑞其实才是初代潘尼怀斯吗？这对我来说排第二。太吓人了。
TV movie. Yeah, I mean, technically it's like mini series, but yeah. Yeah. Fucking weird. Okay. Two. I mean, talk about iconic, dude. Jesus Christ.
电视电影。对，严格来说它是个迷你剧，但对。太他妈诡异了。好吧。第二。我的意思是，说到标志性，老兄。耶稣基督。
Yeah. Yeah. Two. Okay. Wadsworth in Clue. See, now we're fucked, dude. Because I'm going to have to give something, but I might have to give something a five now that I really am upset about.
对。对。第二。好吧，《线索》里的沃兹沃思。看吧，现在我们完蛋了，老兄。因为我得把某个东西，但我现在可能得把一个我真的很生气的作品排到第五位。
Yeah, but. I mean, dude, this is my, when I think of Tim Curry, I have clue. I'm in clue. And also, if you haven't seen Clue in a while, it's so fucking perfect. It's like, sometimes things get adapted and I'm like, what are we doing? And that is like a, I'm like, oh, of course. Was that the first time they took a board game and turned it into a movie? Great question.
对，但是。我的意思是，老兄，这是我的，当我想到蒂姆·库瑞时，我脑子里就是《线索》。我身处《线索》之中。而且，如果你有一段时间没看过《线索》了，它真的是完美得他妈的无可挑剔。就像，有时有些作品被改编后，我会想，我们在搞什么鬼？而那部电影就像是一个，我会想，哦，当然啦。那是他们第一次把桌游改编成电影吗？好问题。
It might be. That would be awesome. Yeah, maybe. That's the one to do. Like, if you're going to turn any board game into a movie, I'm like, yeah, clue. That's an obvious one. Yeah, yeah. I'm going one.
可能是吧。那可太酷了。对，也许吧。这就是应该拍的电影。如果你要把任何桌游拍成电影，我会觉得，对，《线索》。这简直显而易见。对，对。我选第一。
I think we unfortunately have to go one, which means I know I'm about to fucking dad. a movie I truly love. Okay, are we daggering this one? Muppet Treasurer. I knew it, dude. I literally fucking knew this was going to be it, dude. Like, I would have put this at one, Dan. I literally would have put this at fucking one,
我觉得我们不幸地只能选第一，这意味着我知道我马上要……去爸的。一部我真心深爱的电影。好吧，我们要把这部电影当做牺牲品吗？《布偶金银岛》。我就知道，老兄。我他妈的简直就知道会是这个，老兄。我本来会把它排在第一位，丹。我本来真的会把它排在他妈的第一位，
and now it's five on my blind ranking. God damn it, dude. That is a nightmare. I'm fine with this. I'm totally fine with this. You're so wrong. You're so wrong. No, no, no.
而现在它在我的盲评里成了第五位。该死，老兄。这简直是一场噩梦。我完全可以接受。我真的完全可以接受。你大错特错了。你大错特错了。不，不，不。
No disrespect. Muppert Treasure Island. I love that. But like, the four in front of it are all the timers. This movie, dude. This movie. Guys, think about, think about, this is, okay, I understand this might not, this might not reflect your personal taste, but number five, but he's also got movies like Fern Gully, I know, wild thornberry. Yeah, yeah.
没有不尊重。《布偶金银岛》。我爱死这部电影了。但排在它前面的那四个都是永恒的经典。这部电影，老兄。这部电影。伙计们，想想看，想想看，这是，好吧，我明白这可能不，这可能不符合你们的个人品味，但排在第五位，而且他还有像《仙谷》这样的电影，我知道，还有《荒野野玫瑰》。对，对。
Like, so many other, like legend, he was the devil in that movie legend. Oh, yeah. Yeah, dude. I'm really glad. I am, I will say this, as sad as I am that Muppet Treasure Island is my five now on record forever, because the internet will never die. But I'm glad it wasn't Fern Gulley, yeah, because that would have been, we would have never recovered from that. I would have logged I would have logged
就像，还有那么多其他的，传奇作品，他在《魔幻迷宫》里演过魔鬼。哦，对。对，老兄。我真的很庆幸。我必须说，尽管我很伤心《布偶金银岛》现在永远留在记录上成了我的第五名，因为互联网永远不会消失。但我很高兴它不是《仙谷》，对，因为如果是那样的话，我们永远都缓不过劲来了。我当时就会，我当时就会……
off of this episode immediately and retired I would have retired but I just I assumed knowing Evan he was not going to put an animated out of that
立刻退出这期节目并宣布退休，我绝对会退休的。但我只是，我以为以我对埃文的了解，他不会把一部动画片放在那里的。
I did want to keep it to live action so that it wasn't the Sophie's choice for you guys thank you because Hexas one of the great villains
我确实想把它限定在真人电影里，免得对你们来说这成了《苏菲的选择》，谢谢你们，因为海克萨斯绝对是有史以来最伟大的反派之一，
of all time in one of the greatest animated films of all time that would have been one I mean dude Tim Curry we know what I really
出自有史以来最伟大的动画电影之一，那绝对会是一个。我的意思是，老兄，蒂姆·库瑞，你知道我真正喜欢的是什么吗？首先，我其实觉得我们表现得相当不错。确实不错。其次，我觉得如果我们能在任何一期节目中做点什么来回馈世界，我希望我们能激发大家这周去看几部蒂姆·库瑞的电影。
love about this first of all I actually think we did a very good job you did and second of all I think if any time we do an episode, we hope to do something to give back to the world, I hope we inspire people to watch some Tim Carrey movies this week.
因为，真他妈的，你说得对，埃文，这家伙的职业生涯简直传奇。对，绝对是杰出的演员。太传奇了。这是一期精彩的节目，伙计们。我们接下来还有很多有趣的内容。如果你还没看过，昨天刚播出了《红星崛起》第五集。确保去补一下，这样剧情就接上了。第一本书的内容我们只剩下最后两集了。
Because, God damn, you were right, Ev, like this man had a phenomenal career. Yeah, excellent actor. Phenomenal. That's a beautiful episode, folks. We've got fun stuff coming out. If you didn't check it out yet, episode five of Red Rising dropped yesterday. Make sure to watch that so you're caught up. We only have two Eps left of the first book of the series.
我们有超赞的周边在售。去看看吧。在苹果播客上给我们打五星好评。在 Spotify 上也是。现在就暂停。在结束这期节目之前，现在就去给我们做这件事，然后订阅我们的 YouTube 频道。
We've got unbelievable merch available. go check it out. Give us five stars on Apple. Spotify. Pause right now. Before you end this episode, go do that for us right now, then subscribe to the YouTube.
我们太爱你们了。祝大家度过一个绝对安全、充满乐趣的周末。随着我们向冰球赛季发起冲刺，接下来几周我们还会为你们带来精彩绝伦的采访。太棒了。我们爱你们。直到我们下次再见。
We love you guys so much. Have an incredibly safe, fun weekend. We've got amazing interviews coming up for you in the next couple of weeks as we rip up towards hockey season. Beautiful stuff. We love you guys. Until we see you next time.
努力滑冰。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何一句话即可留下评论。
Skate hard. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
努力滑板。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。